Even citizens found their city confusing. The only way to negotiate it was to memorize notable landmarks, the fig tree perhaps, or a market's colonnade, or best of all, a temple large enough to loom above the maze of narrow streets. Fortunately, Rome was a devout city, and temples abounded. The Romans' reverence for the past meant that ancient structures were hardly ever demolished, not even when the open spaces in which they might once have stood had long since vanished under brick.
即使是市民也觉得他们的城市令人困惑。在城中穿行的唯一方法就是记住著名的地标，也许是一棵无花果树，或者市场的柱廊，或者最好是那种大到足以在狭窄街道迷宫上方耸立的寺庙。幸运的是，罗马是一座虔诚的城市，寺庙比比皆是。罗马人对过去的崇敬意味着古老的建筑几乎从未被拆除，即使是那些曾经可能存在过的开阔空间，也早已消失在砖墙之下。
Temples loomed over slums or meat markets. They shentered, veiled statues whose very identities might have been forgotten, and yet no one ever thought to demolish them. These fragments of an archaic past preserved in stone, fossils from the earliest days of the city provided the Romans with a desperately needed sense of bearing. Eternal, like the gods whose spirits pervades,
寺庙耸立在贫民窟或肉市场之上。它们庇护着那些身份可能已被遗忘的蒙面雕像，然而没有人想过要拆除它们。这些保存在石头里的古老过去的碎片，这些来自城市最早时期的化石，为罗马人提供了一种急需的方向感。它们像神灵一样永恒，神灵的精神弥漫在
them, they stood like anchors dropped in a storm. Meanwhile, on all sides, amid a din of hammering, rumbling wagon wheels and crashing rubble, the city was endlessly being rebuilt, torn down, and rebuilt again. Now, that's a description of Rome, the great teeming city, the great metropolis of the Mediterranean world. And listeners may be wondering, Which great writer, which master of the English language constructed those sentences? Was it Edward Gibbon? Was it Dan Brown? Well, dear listeners, it was our very own Tom Holland in his book Rubicon, the book that catapulted him to greatness.
它们之中，它们就像暴风雨中抛下的锚。与此同时，在四面八方，在锤击声、隆隆的马车轮声和崩塌的瓦砾声中，这座城市不断地被重建、拆除，然后再重建。现在，这是对罗马的描述，这座熙熙攘攘的伟大城市，地中海世界的伟大都市。听众们可能在想，是哪位伟大的作家，哪位英语语言大师构建了这些句子？是爱德华·吉本吗？是丹·布朗吗？好吧，亲爱的听众们，这是我们自己的汤姆·霍兰在他那本《卢比孔河》中所写的，正是这本书让他一举成名。
So Tom, Rome, 105 BC, biggest city in the Mediterranean. It's not yet the mega city that it will become under the Emperor Augustus 100 years later. It's probably about 400, 500,000 people, max. But to visitors, as your wonderful prose conveyed, it is overwhelming, isn't it? Rather like your prose, actually. I think for visitors, it's experienced as a kind of monstrous city. It's crowded, it's confusing, it's completely chaotic. It has this terrible haze of brown smog which hangs over it and which can be seen, you know,
那么汤姆，公元前105年的罗马，地中海最大的城市。它还不是100年后在奥古斯都皇帝统治下将要成为的那种超级城市。它的人口可能最多也就40、50万。但对于游客来说，正如你精彩的散文所传达的那样，它是令人难以承受的，不是吗？实际上，这很像你的散文。我想对于游客来说，它被体验为一种怪物般的城市。它拥挤、混乱、完全无序。它笼罩着一层可怕的褐色烟雾，你可以在
many, many miles before you actually see the city itself. And then you arrive in the city and it's crammed with teetering, jerry-built apartment blocks. Insuli, they were called islands. They were kind of islands rising above the chaos of the streets below, in which are notorious as death traps. And if there's a fire and you are on the top stories, I mean, that's it. you're burnt to a cinder. And everywhere there are kind of shanties sprouting up. So if there's a fire, the shanties will immediately emerge in the space that's been left. And they're spreading out through the gates along the roads that lead into Rome. And there is also an incredible lack of
在真正看到城市本身之前的许多英里外就能看到它。然后你到达城市，里面挤满了摇摇欲坠、粗制滥造的公寓楼。它们被称为“岛屿”（Insulae）。它们就像从下面街道的混乱中升起的岛屿，以死亡陷阱而闻名。如果发生火灾，而你住在顶层，我的意思是，那就完了。你会烧成灰烬。到处都是不断涌现的棚户区。所以如果发生火灾，棚户区会立即在留出的空间里冒出来。它们沿着通往罗马的道路穿过城门蔓延开来。而且这里还极其缺乏
the kind of monumental architecture that most people, I imagine, when they think of ancient Rome, would be in their mind's eye. Rome in this period is not the Rome of gladiator. There are no amphitheaters. are no palaces, there's very little gleaming marble. And so Greek ambassadors who are used to exactly that kind of cityscape, things that are elegant, that are planned, that are spacious, that are centrally organized. When they come to Rome, they think this is an absolute dump. I suppose it's like someone from New York going to a third world city, something like that. They think it's backward, they think it's ramshackle, they think it's disorganized.
大多数人在想到古罗马时脑海中浮现的那种纪念性建筑。这一时期的罗马不是《角斗士》里的罗马。没有圆形剧场，没有宫殿，几乎没有闪闪发光的大理石。所以那些习惯了那种城市景观——优雅、规划有序、宽敞、中心化组织——的希腊大使们，当他们来到罗马时，他们认为这绝对是个垃圾场。我想这就像一个纽约人去第三世界城市一样，类似那样。他们认为它落后、破旧、杂乱无章。
But the Roman response to this is to say that the chaos of their city is the index of its liberty. The kings can impose urban plans on cities because they are autocrats. But because Rome is a republic and its great men are much too jealous of one another to allow any of them to build kind of pompous imposing monuments, this means that its chaotic, brick-fronted cityscape is an expression of the fact that the Romans are a free people. And it's telling that it's only under the rule of Augustus, the first of the Caesars, the first of the autocrats, that it will start its transformation into a city from brick into marble. He's the Napoleon III of Roman history.
但罗马人对此的回应是，他们城市的混乱是其自由的标志。国王们可以强行在城市上实施城市规划，因为他们是独裁者。但因为罗马是一个共和国，其伟人之间嫉妒心太强，不允许任何人建造那种浮夸、宏伟的纪念碑，这意味着它那混乱的砖墙城市景观，是罗马人作为一个自由民族这一事实的表达。而且值得注意的是，只有在第一位凯撒、第一位独裁者奥古斯都的统治下，它才开始从砖城向大理石城的转变。他是罗马历史上的拿破仑三世。
So Napoleon III who transforms Paris. Well, I think Napoleon the third is surely the would be Augustus. Yeah, correct. because also Napoleon III was an absolutely ludicrous man, whereas Augustus was arguably the greatest politician who ever lived. Anyway, that's by the by. So Rome 105 BC. One thing obsesses the city more than anything else,
那么改造巴黎的拿破仑三世。嗯，我认为拿破仑三世肯定是一个想成为奥古斯都的人。是的，没错。因为拿破仑三世也是一个绝对荒谬的人，而奥古斯都可以说是历史上最伟大的政治家。总之，那是题外话。那么公元前105年的罗马。有一件事比其他任何事情都让这座城市着迷，
and that, of course, is politics, because we ended last time with the great political drama of Marius, effectively stabbing his patron, Mattelus in the back. But Marius, you ended last time by saying how worried Marius was about his own lieutenant, Sulla, and we will come on to this. But just give us a sense. So it's a great kind of theatre, isn't it?
当然就是政治，因为我们上次以马略那场伟大的政治闹剧结束，他实际上是在背后捅了他的赞助人梅特鲁斯一刀。但是马略，你上次结束时说马略对他自己的副手苏拉有多么担心，我们稍后会谈到这一点。但先给我们一个感觉。所以这是一种伟大的戏剧，不是吗？
It's a theatre for political show. It's a great stage, yes. That's why Romans don't feel that they need to have a kind of cultural cringe towards the Greeks because Greeks are all ruled by monarchs or indeed by Rome. But the Romans are a free people. And it is their right to elect their own magistrates. And so the city is constantly bearing witness to this. Everywhere you go there is graffiti.
这是一个政治表演的剧场，是的，一个伟大的舞台。这就是为什么罗马人不需要对希腊人产生某种文化上的自卑感，因为希腊人都是由君主统治的，或者实际上是由罗马统治的。但罗马人是一个自由的民族。他们有权选举自己的地方长官。所以这座城市不断地见证着这一点。无论你走到哪里，都有涂鸦。
If people don't like candidates, then they may, you know, they may literally piss on them. Wow. So, you know, if there are kind of statues of them, they will go and express their contempt for them in the most literal manner. There's a hint for people if they have strong views about Britain's politicians. I suppose they don't tend to have statues, but there might be alternative ways in which they could do that. Yeah. And we said in the previous episode how Marius, while he's in Africa, his agents are busy promoting his name. I mean, this is the chief of which
如果人们不喜欢候选人，那么他们可能会，你知道，他们可能会直接在他们身上撒尿。哇。所以，你知道，如果那里有他们的雕像，他们会去以最直白的方式表达对他们的蔑视。如果人们对英国的政治家有强烈的看法，这里有一个提示。我想他们往往没有雕像，但可能有其他方式可以做到这一点。是的。我们在上一集说过，马略在非洲时，他的代理人正忙着宣传他的名字。我的意思是，这是他们做这件事的主要方式，
they're doing it. They're going around writing graffiti, pissing on his rivals, all of that. And so I guess Rome stands supreme as the great theatre of ambitions and dreams. There's nowhere like it anywhere else in the world. This is way you have to be if you want to shape politics. And as a citizen of Rome, you have the opportunity to do that, either by running as a candidate or even if you're, you know, the very poorest of the poor, you have a vote. Your opinion. matters. Right. So, although Rome is the Republic, there is one man in 105 BC who stands head and shoulders above all his rivals, who in a sense is the preenkeps, the top man of the city. And this is Gaius Marius, the protagonist of our first episode. And we tracked his early career in that
他们到处写涂鸦，在对手身上撒尿，诸如此类。所以我猜罗马作为雄心和梦想的伟大剧场处于至高无上的地位。世界上没有任何地方像它一样。如果你想塑造政治，你就必须在这里。作为罗马公民，你有机会这样做，无论是作为候选人参选，还是即使你是最贫穷的人，你也有投票权。你的意见很重要。对。所以，虽然罗马是共和国，但在公元前105年，有一个人高出他所有的竞争对手，在某种意义上他是“首席”（princeps），是这座城市的头号人物。这就是盖乌斯·马略，我们第一集的主角。我们在那一集里追踪了他的早期职业生涯。
episode. So he's an out-of-towner, he's burly, he's uncultured, but he's a natural politician. he's a brilliant soldier. And in 108, he'd been elected consul, so the top magistrate in the Roman Republic, because the voters and the Senate were fed up with a war that had been dragging on in Numidia, in North Africa, what's now Algeria, and they wanted it sorted out. And Maris had been the guy that they had said, go and sort this out. And it is amazing that Marius had ever got the nod, because he is what the Romans called a novice homo,
所以他是一个外地人，他身材魁梧，没有文化，但他是一个天生的政治家。他是一个出色的士兵。在公元前108年，他被选为执政官，也就是罗马共和国的最高长官，因为选民和元老院对在努米底亚（现在的阿尔及利亚）拖延已久的战争感到厌倦，他们想解决这个问题。马略就是他们说“去解决这个问题”的那个人。马略竟然能得到认可真是令人惊讶，因为他是罗马人所说的“新人”（novus homo），
a man without any consular pedigree, and these things really matter to the voters. So if you're a novice homo and you get elected, it's a massive, massive deal. And it's huge tribute to his reputation because it essentially marks him out as the go-to person if there is some massive military crisis. Yeah. So he has come back to Rome, late 105, and he came back with Jagirtha of Earlobe's fame, the bloke whose earrings were ripped off at the end of the last episode. enemy who grins horribly as he's being chucked into a dungeon.
一个没有任何执政官血统的人，这些东西对选民来说真的很重要。所以如果你是一个“新人”并且当选了，那是一件非常非常大的事情。这对他声誉的巨大赞誉，因为它本质上标志着如果发生某种巨大的军事危机，他就是首选人物。是的。所以他在公元前105年末回到罗马，他带着朱古达（Jugurtha）——那个以耳垂闻名的人，那个在上一集结尾耳环被扯掉的家伙。那个在被扔进地牢时还在恐怖地咧嘴笑的敌人。
Right. Or all the baths as cold as this or whatever great banter. Mad banter, Jagertha came out with as he was on his way to his demise. But more importantly, Marius has come back to Rome with his number two. So he's a man who really first featured at the end of the last episode. And this is Lucius Cornelius Sulla. It's the man with whom Marius, in all the history books, is always bracketed. And you described him last time, golden-haired, patrician, daring, swashbuckling, all of this.
对。或者“澡堂有这么冷吗”之类的伟大俏皮话。疯狂的俏皮话，朱古达在走向灭亡的路上说出来的。但更重要的是，马略带着他的二把手回到了罗马。所以他是一个在上一集结尾真正首次亮相的人。这就是卢修斯·科尔内利乌斯·苏拉（Lucius Cornelius Sulla）。在所有的历史书中，他总是与马略并列。你上次描述过他，金发、贵族、大胆、好斗，所有这些。
And Sulla has made his name during, I mean, he's really made his name, hasn't he, in the campaign against Gagirtha? In a way that Maris finds, his boss finds a little bit unsettling. Yeah, because Gherth had fled to the neighbouring king. And so it required a mission of great daring to get him out from there. And Sulla had gone in, I mean, he might easily have been killed, but he is. He's very brave and he's very diplomatically skilled and he manages to extract Gigertha and bring him back for his horrible death in a dungeon in Rome. And Sulla is enormously proud of this.
苏拉在……我的意思是，他在对阵朱古达的战役中真正成名了，不是吗？以一种马略——他的老板——觉得有点不安的方式。是的，因为朱古达逃到了邻国国王那里。所以需要一次非常大胆的任务才能把他从那里弄出来。苏拉进去了，我的意思是，他很容易被杀，但他非常勇敢，而且外交技巧娴熟，他成功地抓住了朱古达，并把他带回罗马接受可怕的死亡。苏拉对此感到非常自豪。
The Romans are not people who approve of modesty. And so he has had a signet ring made which illustrates the process by which Gigertha is being handed over by the king who he'd taken refuge with. And this infuriates Marius and we will be hearing more. about Sulla in due course in this episode. But for now, it's all about Marius, because on the 1st of January 104 BC, as we described at the end of our last episode, Marius celebrates this great triumph, this military parade through Rome, in which he's able to display Gigertha, display his treasure, all his legions who'd fought with him on that campaign are cheering him. It's great.
罗马人不是那种赞成谦虚的人。所以他制作了一枚印章戒指，上面展示了朱古达被他避难的国王移交的过程。这激怒了马略，我们将在本集的适当时候听到更多关于苏拉的消息。但现在，一切都关于马略，因为在公元前104年1月1日，正如我们在上一集结尾所描述的那样，马略庆祝了这场伟大的凯旋式，这场穿过罗马的军事游行，他能够展示朱古达，展示他的战利品，所有在战役中与他并肩作战的军团都在为他欢呼。太棒了。
I mean, you couldn't want for anything more if you're a Roman general. It's absolutely brilliant. And he rides in this chariot. He's a raid in triumphal robes. I think the idea that you have a slave who stands behind you and says, remember, you're immortal. It's not 100% validated. But you can absolutely see why that story emerges. There is a sense that this is the greatest kind of experience that any Roman can have. However, even as Marius is riding through the streets of Rome and being cheered by the watching
我的意思是，如果你是一个罗马将军，你不会想要更多了。这绝对是辉煌的。他坐在战车里。他身穿凯旋长袍。我认为有一个奴隶站在你身后说“记住，你是凡人”的想法，并不是100%被证实的。但你绝对可以看出这个故事为什么会出现。有一种感觉，这是任何罗马人所能拥有的最伟大的体验。然而，即使马略正骑着马穿过罗马的街道，受到围观群众的欢呼，
crowds, there is a mood of panic, maybe even desperation in the city, because Jagurtha may have been defeated. The dignity of the Roman name may have been upheld in Africa, but to the north, beyond the Alps, there is a much more terrifying threat than some African king, massing on the frontiers of Rome's empire. And again, we mentioned. this in the previous episode. Yeah. It's an immense migration of Germans, the Teutans and the Kimbray from Jutland to the frontiers of the Roman world.
城市里也有一种恐慌，甚至可能是绝望的情绪，因为朱古达可能已经被击败了。罗马名字的尊严可能在非洲得到了维护，但在北方，阿尔卑斯山之外，有一个比什么非洲国王更可怕的威胁，正在罗马帝国的边境集结。我们再次在上一集提到了这一点。是的。这是一场巨大的德国人迁徙，来自日德兰半岛的条顿人和辛布里人，正向罗马世界的边境进发。
So it's almost a kind of proto-viking invasion. Yeah. So in the last episode, to please people who online like to count how often we refer to either the Lord of the Rings or Game of Thrones, I compared them with the white walkers, the people who in the Game of Thrones TV series you see right at the beginning, they're massing all the time. You know, all the internal politics of West Ross is nothing compared with the existential apocalyptic threat that these blokes represent. And actually, I'm going to congratulate myself on my own comparison. I think it's an absolutely superb comparison. Yeah. Because, I mean,
所以这几乎是一种原始的维京入侵。是的。所以在上一集，为了取悦那些在网上喜欢统计我们提到《指环王》或《权力的游戏》频率的人，我把他们比作“异鬼”（White Walkers），那些在《权力的游戏》电视剧里你从一开始就看到的，他们一直在集结。你知道，维斯特洛所有的内部政治与这些家伙代表的生存末日威胁相比根本不算什么。实际上，我要为我自己的比较自我祝贺一下。我认为这是一个绝对绝妙的比较。是的。因为，我的意思是，
these people, the Teutons and the Kimbray, they're massive, they're terrifying, they look weird, they are an existential threat. They're reputed to be cannibals. Right. This is Plutarch on them. He said they were impervious to cold because they'd been brought up in icebound countries full of forests. I mean, Tom, the parallels are stacking up. You're absolutely right. And also, I think, isn't this also the case with the White Walkers? The Tutans and the Kimbrey accompanied by women and children. Yeah, because some of them are women and children, yeah.
这些人，条顿人和辛布里人，他们庞大、可怕、看起来很怪异，他们是一个生存威胁。他们被传说是食人族。对。这是普鲁塔克对他们的描述。他说他们对寒冷有免疫力，因为他们是在充满森林的冰封国家长大的。我的意思是，汤姆，相似之处正在堆积。你是绝对正确的。而且，我认为，这不也是异鬼的情况吗？条顿人和辛布里人由妇女和儿童陪同。是的，因为他们中有些人是妇女和儿童，是的。
And in fact, actually, in Game of Thrones, the children are the most frightening. There's always something terrifying about a murderous, sinister child. And frankly, if you've ever met a German child, you know, it's the same story. Well, they're Danes, really, aren't they? Yeah, they're the worst. And the women also are very frightening because they're said to fight alongside the men. Of course. And it's an entire people on the move.
事实上，在《权力的游戏》中，孩子们是最可怕的。一个凶残、阴险的孩子总是有某种可怕之处。坦率地说，如果你见过一个德国孩子，你知道，情况是一样的。嗯，他们其实是丹麦人，不是吗？是的，他们是最糟糕的。而且妇女也非常可怕，因为据说她们与男人并肩作战。当然。这是一个正在移动的整个民族。
So there are tens of thousands of them, according to the Roman sources. I mean, we don't know how accurate they are. But basically, there are loads and loads of them. And they are experienced by the Romans less as an army than as some kind of force of nature. You know, a great flood, a tide, a tsunami, whatever you want to reach for. You know, the news had been brought to them that this monstrous tide of people is advancing towards you. And so they sent an army under a consul into a region called Norikum, which is basically Austria today, in 113 BC. And the consul had set an ambush for these barbarians, and the barbarians had rumbled it and had outsmarted the consul and given him a serious mawling.
所以根据罗马史料，他们有数万人。我的意思是，我们不知道这些数字有多准确。但基本上，他们非常非常多。罗马人体验到的他们与其说是一支军队，不如说是一种自然力量。你知道，一场大洪水、潮汐、海啸，无论你想用什么词。你知道，消息传给他们说这股巨大的潮汐正在向你推进。所以他们在公元前113年派了一支由执政官率领的军队进入一个叫诺里库姆（Noricum）的地区，也就是今天的奥地利。执政官为这些野蛮人设下了埋伏，但野蛮人识破了它，并智胜了执政官，给了他一次严重的打击。
And so he'd withdrawn. and he had assumed that the barbarians would pursue him and invade Italy. In fact, they don't. They swing westwards into Gaul, which is a big relief to the Romans. But I think it's also a little bit unsettling because it's clear that the Kimberian and the Teutons are unlike any enemy that they've come up against before. There's no predicting what they'll do. When you're fighting Carthaginians or Greeks or even Gauls, there's a sense in which the Romans understand what makes these people tick. But with these barbarians from the far north, and again, this is maybe the kind of White Walker
所以他撤退了。他以为野蛮人会追击他并入侵意大利。事实上，他们没有。他们向西转向高卢，这对罗马人来说是一个巨大的解脱。但我认为这也有一点令人不安，因为很明显，辛布里人和条顿人与他们之前遇到的任何敌人都不同。无法预测他们会做什么。当你与迦太基人或希腊人甚至高卢人作战时，罗马人在某种意义上了解是什么让这些人行动。但对于这些来自遥远北方的野蛮人，同样，这也许是那种“异鬼”的比较，
comparison, the Romans don't understand what they want, they don't understand what's going to motivate them, they don't understand how they're going to behave. And so that means it's very difficult, I think, for the Romans to devise a strategy to cope with this onslaught. And this becomes manifest in a succession of disastrous Roman attempts to go and be proactive and meet the Tutans and Kimbury and wipe them out beyond the limits of Roman power. Because the barbarians, they're just roaming around Gaul, kind of looting and pillaging and killing and all that kind of stuff.
罗马人不明白他们想要什么，不明白是什么在激励他们，不明白他们会如何表现。所以这意味着，我认为，罗马人很难制定出应对这种猛攻的策略。这在随后一系列灾难性的罗马尝试中变得显而易见，他们试图主动出击，去迎接条顿人和辛布里人，并在罗马权力的范围之外消灭他们。因为野蛮人，他们只是在高卢到处游荡，进行掠夺、抢劫、杀戮等等。
And the Romans keep going and trying to attack them, and they keep being defeated. So first in 109 BC and then two years later near what today is Bordeaux. And one consul in that battle is killed. And the other one is cornered. And the only way that he can extract himself is to agree that he and his army will go beneath the yoke. Oh, my God. Yeah, ultimate humiliation. You put up, you know, two spears and put another spear across it.
罗马人不断地试图攻击他们，却不断地被击败。所以首先是在公元前109年，然后是两年后在今天的波尔多附近。在那场战斗中，一位执政官被杀。另一位被逼入绝境。他能脱身的唯一方法就是同意他和他的军队从“轭下”走过。哦，天哪。是的，终极羞辱。你竖起两根长矛，在上面横放另一根长矛。
And everyone has to symbolically bend and crawl. Well, not symbolically. I mean, you literally do it. But it's obviously a symbol of humiliation. So that's very bad. And then I had forgotten the full details of this defeat. So it happens in 105. And it's a culminating disaster.
每个人都必须象征性地弯腰爬过去。嗯，不是象征性的。我的意思是，你真的要这样做。但这显然是一种羞辱的象征。所以这非常糟糕。然后我忘记了这次失败的全部细节。它发生在105年。这是一场灾难的高潮，
in the Roman attempts to stop the barbarians. It happens outside Arousio, which is the town in Southern Gaul, which gives its name to Orange. So ultimately, to the Orange Order. I mean, that's an amazing thought. And in this battle, the Romans, it said, lose over 100,000 men, which is more than they lose in Can I. Is that plausible, really, that they lost that many?
在罗马试图阻止野蛮人的尝试中。它发生在阿劳西奥（Arausio）之外，这是高卢南部的一个城镇，它给了奥兰治（Orange）这个名字。所以最终，给了奥兰治令（Orange Order）。我的意思是，那是一个惊人的想法。在那场战斗中，据说罗马人损失了超过10万名士兵，这比他们在坎尼战役中损失的还要多。这真的可信吗，他们损失了那么多人？
I mean, these figures are all made up, aren't they, really? I don't think they're made up. It's clearly a massive defeat, and yet it's barely remembered, and you think how much it's written about can I and the impact that it had on the Romans. At the time, it must have just seemed overwhelming. It must have seemed a disaster on par with that. And when the news of it is brought to Rome, there is this terrible mood of panic, and they call it the terror Kimbrichus. And that phrase ever afterwards is applied by the Romans to a kind of mood of civic panic. you know, the kind of the mood of terror that can sweep an entire city.
我的意思是，这些数字都是编造的，不是吗，真的？我不认为它们是编造的。这显然是一场巨大的失败，然而它几乎被遗忘了，你想到人们对坎尼战役写了多少，以及它对罗马人产生的影响。当时，它一定看起来是压倒性的。它一定看起来是一场与之相当的灾难。当消息传到罗马时，有一种可怕的恐慌情绪，他们称之为“辛布里恐怖”（terror Cimbricus）。从那以后，这个短语被罗马人用来形容一种城市恐慌的情绪。你知道，那种可以席卷整个城市的恐怖情绪。
Right. And everyone, even Marius's old enemies in the Senate, agree that basically, faced with this crisis, there is only one man for the job. Obviously, I mean, this is Marius. So Rousier was 105. Then in 104, Marius has been elected as one of the two consorts, hasn't he, for the year? So this is his second consulship already. You said, remember Plutarch. that he, well, Pluto reported the prophecy that he would get seven. And you said he'd be a big
对。每个人，甚至马略在元老院的老对手，都同意基本上，面对这场危机，只有一个人能胜任这项工作。显然，我的意思是，这就是马略。所以阿劳西奥是在105年。然后在104年，马略被选为当年的两位执政官之一，不是吗？所以这已经是他的第二次执政官任期了。你说，记住普鲁塔克。他，嗯，普鲁塔克报道了预言说他会得到七次。你说他要得到哪怕一次都是一个很大的挑战。
stretch from to get even worn. You were wrong, Tom. He's now got two. To justify myself, we also said in the previous episode that it is essentially, it's either illegal or massively frowned upon for someone who's had a consulship then to have a second consulship. Yeah, you did. You did say that. And if you do have a second consulship, then at the very least it should be at a kind of decent distance from the original one. But Marius, he'd be consulate 107. This is only three years later. So that, I think, is the measure of the state of absolute panic that everyone in Rome is feeling, that they haven't really got any choice. Constitutional proprieties don't really count
汤姆，你错了。他现在已经有了两次。为了证明我自己，我们在上一集也说过，对于一个已经担任过执政官的人来说，再担任第二次执政官基本上要么是非法的，要么是受到极大反对的。是的，你确实说了。而且如果你确实有第二次执政官任期，那么至少它应该与最初的任期保持一定的距离。但马略，他在107年担任执政官。这仅仅是三年后。所以，我认为，这就是罗马每个人都感到的绝对恐慌状态的衡量标准，他们真的别无选择。宪法礼仪并不真正算数，
when your city is facing an existential threat. And so it is that as Marius is riding through the streets of Rome in his triumphal robes on his chariot, enjoying his triumph. you've got to wonder, you know, if that story was true, if the nest full of seven eaglets fell into his arms, and it did indeed prophesy that he was going to have seven consulships. I mean, is he thinking about that? Maybe. It would be nice to think so. Yeah. Although there is still tension, isn't there? I mean, he is still a self-made man. He is still an outsider. There must be people in Rome from the old elite who are just like, really this guy? this parvenu again. Yeah, for sure. And Marius, on the day of his triumph, the day that he also takes up his second consulship, he makes a massive power play because he goes straight to the meeting of the Senate wearing his triumphal robes, which is very much not the dumb thing. And he apologised for it and goes and changes. But you have to think, you know, he's reminding everybody in the Senate that he is the guy who has already won one war and that they're depending on to win a second one.
当你的城市面临生存威胁时。所以，当马略身穿凯旋长袍坐在战车上穿过罗马街道，享受他的凯旋时，你不得不怀疑，你知道，如果那个故事是真的，如果那窝七只小鹰掉进他的怀里，并且确实预言了他将拥有七次执政官任期。我的意思是，他在想那个吗？也许吧。如果能这样想就太好了。是的。虽然仍然有紧张气氛，不是吗？我的意思是，他仍然是一个白手起家的人。他仍然是一个局外人。罗马一定有来自旧精英阶层的人，他们就像，真的是这个家伙？这个暴发户又来了。是的，当然。在凯旋的那一天，也就是他开始第二次执政官任期的那一天，马略进行了一次巨大的权力博弈，因为他直接穿着凯旋长袍去参加元老院会议，这非常不合规矩。他为此道歉并去换了衣服。但你必须想到，你知道，他在提醒元老院里的每个人，他是已经赢得了一场战争的人，他们正指望他赢得第二场战争。
So it causes indignation, but I think Maris probably felt it was worth the indignation. The Senate doesn't give him sole command. So there is still, you know, he is one of two consuls. So Maris's enemies can feel, well, at least he's not, you know, his power is not completely preponderant. He still has a colleague at the top. Right. But I think it is a measure of the emergency and of Maris's reputation as Rome's only
所以这引起了愤慨，但我认为马略可能觉得这值得引起愤慨。元老院并没有给他唯一的指挥权。所以仍然有，你知道，他是两位执政官之一。所以马略的敌人可以感觉到，好吧，至少他不是，你知道，他的权力不是完全压倒性的。他在最高层仍然有一位同事。对。但我认为这是紧急情况的衡量标准，也是马略作为罗马唯一
plausible saviour that throughout this war against the Kimbrey that's going to be fought and it stretches from from 104 BC to 101, he's going to hold consecutive consulships. So that's four consulships on top of his previous one. So that's five consulships. And just to emphasize, this is something completely unprecedented. So this is a little by Franklin D. Roosevelt serving, you know, winning four elections in the 1930s and 1940s. It's unprecedented. It violates not the letter of the constitution, but the spread.
可能的救世主的声誉的衡量标准，在整个这场将要进行的对抗辛布里人的战争中，它从公元前104年一直持续到101年，他将连续担任执政官。所以那是他之前的任期之外的四次执政官任期。所以那是五次执政官任期。而且要强调的是，这是完全史无前例的。所以这有点像富兰克林·D·罗斯福在20世纪30年代和40年代赢得了四次选举。这是史无前例的。它违反的不是宪法的条文，而是
spirit of it, but the established tradition. But people see it as a reasonable reaction to times of existential threat, unprecedented in their history. And that's the analogy, I suppose. That's the measure, I think, of the threat that Rome feels that it is facing. Yeah. And also the degree to which Marius is really the one person they feel can sort this out. Now, Marius, it has to be said, is not a flamboyant general. He's not Alexander the Great. He's not even Julius. Caesar. He is a guy who is basically all about digging ditches and latrines and routine. That's very much what the Romans in military terms are about. Isn't that like what the Scipio's had been like, though, had they not been like dogged, resolute, managerial, all of that? That is the essence
它的精神，但违反了既定的传统。但人们认为这是对生存威胁时代的合理反应，在他们的历史上是史无前例的。我想这就是类比。我认为，这就是罗马感到它所面临的威胁的衡量标准。是的。而且马略确实是他们觉得唯一能解决这个问题的人。现在，必须说，马略不是一个浮夸的将军。他不是亚历山大大帝。他甚至不是尤利乌斯·凯撒。他是一个基本上只关心挖沟、厕所和日常事务的家伙。这在军事上非常符合罗马人的风格。那不是像西庇阿家族那样吗，难道他们不是那种顽强、果断、善于管理的人吗？这就是
of the Roman military approach. Right. They love, you know, every night they will build a camp. And so Marius goes very much with the grain of this tradition. He bases himself, in the Provincia, the future province, southern Gaul. And he concentrates on building up Rome's battlefield effectiveness, which essentially means focusing on getting his men practiced with spades as much as with arms. You know, he wants to toughen them up. He wants, you know, lots of forced marches carrying heavy boulders, lots of digging trenches, all of that kind of thing. But also imposing discipline, imposing battlefield techniques, all of this kind of stuff. It's often been said that this constitutes a military revolution, what Maris puts his men through in this period, a transformation
罗马军事方法的精髓。对。他们喜欢，你知道，每天晚上他们都会建立一个营地。所以马略非常顺应这一传统。他把自己安置在“行省”（Provincia），即未来的行省，高卢南部。他专注于建立罗马的战场效能，这本质上意味着专注于让他的士兵像练习武器一样练习铲子。你知道，他想让他们变得强硬。他想要，你知道，大量的负重强行军，大量的挖战壕，所有这些事情。但也包括实施纪律，实施战场技术，所有这些东西。人们常说，马略在这一时期让他的士兵经历的事情构成了一场军事革命，一场转变，
in how Rome fights wars. And this is now a very contested topic and people who are interested in this matter. And I think it's a matter of interest, not just for those who are interested in military history, but for the whole sweep of Roman history. It's a really live, fascinating topic. We have a bonus this week with Brett Devereaux. Oh, brilliant. Who has very stimulating opinions on the whole question. So don't miss that. I love this subject and I love Brett Devereaux. And I should be tuning in. Great. I mean, I'm a member of the Restis History Club. Of course. What are people at aunt? How would they listen to it? They could go to therestishistory.com and sign up there. Oh, my gosh. What lovely organic moment that was in the podcast. I know. So unscripted.
关于罗马如何进行战争。现在这是一个非常有争议的话题，对这个问题感兴趣的人。我认为这不仅对那些对军事历史感兴趣的人来说是一个值得关注的问题，而且对整个罗马历史的进程来说也是如此。这是一个非常活跃、迷人的话题。我们这周有一个关于布雷特·德弗罗（Brett Devereaux）的特别节目。哦，太棒了。他对整个问题有非常深刻的见解。所以不要错过。我喜欢这个主题，我也喜欢布雷特·德弗罗。我应该会收听。太棒了。我的意思是，我是“历史的其余部分”（The Rest Is History）俱乐部的成员。当然。人们在哪里听呢？他们可以去 therestishistory.com 并在那里注册。哦，天哪。播客里那个可爱的有机时刻真是太棒了。我知道。那么即兴。
Anyway, right, back to the narrative. Yeah. So whether Marius is instituting a revolution or whether he is just doing tried and tested Roman techniques doesn't matter. He is whipping the Romans into shape. And by 102, he feels ready at last to go on the offensive, not least because by this point, the Teutons and the Kimbury, who previously been travelling in one great kind of amorphous mass, have now gone their own separate ways. Oh, that is a schoolboy error from the Teutons and the Kimbrie madness. Yeah. Listen, they're just barbarians.
总之，对，回到叙事。是的。所以马略是在进行一场革命，还是他只是在做久经考验的罗马技术，这并不重要。他正在把罗马人训练成型。到了公元前102年，他终于觉得准备好发动进攻了，尤其是因为到这个时候，之前一直以一种巨大的无定形群体旅行的条顿人和辛布里人，现在已经分道扬镳了。哦，那是条顿人和辛布里人疯狂的低级错误。是的。听着，他们只是野蛮人。
They don't know better. Crazy. Insane. I have no time for them now. Okay. But the Teutons, who are Maris' first target, they still outnumber Maris's army three to one. Okay. And also, they've beaten the Romans nonstop.
他们不知道更好的。疯狂。精神错乱。我现在没时间理他们了。好的。但条顿人，他们是马略的第一个目标，他们的人数仍然是马略军队的三倍。好的。而且他们一直在不停地击败罗马人。
They don't think there's a problem. And what follows is the kind of classic contrast between Roman disqualification. discipline and barbarian kind of courage and headstrong charging and all that kind of stuff that anyone who's got into the Romans in their childhood will instinctively remember. It's like the opening scene of Gladiator. That's what this is, isn't it? Yes, it absolutely is. I mean, this is basically the kind of contrast that was seared into me when I was obsessed
他们认为没问题。接下来发生的是罗马纪律与野蛮人的勇气、鲁莽冲锋之间那种经典的对比，任何在童年时期迷上罗马人的人都会本能地记住。这就像《角斗士》的开场场景。这就是，不是吗？是的，绝对是。我的意思是，这基本上就是我在大约八岁时迷上罗马人时，深深烙印在我脑海中的那种对比。
by the Romans when I was about eight. So Marius, he approaches the Teutons and then he, he, he approaches the Teutons. And then he builds a big camp, you know, all that digging comes in. And he holds it as a kind of, and basically an impregnable position. And he refuses to answer challenges. And again, this is very gladiator. One of the Teutons comes forward and issues a challenge personally to Marius. And Maris's response is an excellent one.
所以马略，他接近条顿人，然后他，他，他接近条顿人。然后他建立了一个大营地，你知道，所有的挖掘工作都派上了用场。他把它作为一个，基本上是一个坚不可摧的阵地。他拒绝回应挑战。而且，这非常像《角斗士》。其中一个条顿人走上前来，亲自向马略发出挑战。马略的回应是一个绝佳的回应。
If you want death, find a rope, make a noose, and hang yourself. Russell Crow was bored to say that line. It really was. Yeah, he was. They missed a trick there. So the Tuchans hang around issuing these insults. Marius doesn't answer. The Tutons get fed up.
如果你想要死亡，找根绳子，打个结，然后上吊自杀。罗素·克劳很无聊才说那句台词。确实是。是的，他是。他们错过了一个技巧。所以条顿人在那里徘徊，发出这些侮辱。马略没有回答。条顿人厌倦了。
They move on looting, plundering as they go. Marius upsticks, shadows them, building camps every night so they can't be attacked. And then on the banks of the Rhone, he surprises a huge force of a collection of German allies who are traveling with the Tutons and wipes them out. And then four days later, on a plane near a city called Acquise 60i, which is Aixon province, today, he encircles the Teutons. So he does a kind of can-eye and completely wipes them out. They are utterly slaughtered. And so many corpses are left strewn on the battlefield that for years afterwards, the local vintners, it is said, enjoyed the most superlative of vintages. A lovely Provencal Rosey with a hint, just a hint. A little hint of flesh. A rotting teuton.
他们继续前进，一路抢劫、掠夺。马略拔营，跟踪他们，每天晚上建立营地，这样他们就不会被攻击。然后在罗纳河岸边，他突袭了一支庞大的德国盟军部队，他们正与条顿人一起旅行，并消灭了他们。四天后，在今天被称为普罗旺斯地区艾克斯（Aix-en-Provence）的阿奎塞克西（Aquae Sextiae）附近的一个平原上，他包围了条顿人。所以他进行了一次类似坎尼战役的行动，并彻底消灭了他们。他们被彻底屠杀。战场上留下了如此多的尸体，以至于据说多年以后，当地的酿酒师享受到了最顶级的年份酒。一种可爱的普罗旺斯桃红葡萄酒，带有一丝，仅仅是一丝。一丝腐烂条顿人的肉味。
Mmm. Delicious. A little hint of the German corpse. When I drink my fine French wines. Wow. Delicious. This is the rest is history wine tasting tour. Everyone really needed.
嗯。美味。一丝德国尸体的味道。当我喝着我那优质的法国葡萄酒时。哇。美味。这是“历史的其余部分”品酒之旅。每个人都真正需要的。
So the teutons are now gone and basically been turned into fertilizer. grapes. But this still leaves the Kimbury in the field. Yeah. And they, the Romans will not meet with the Kimbrey until the following year. So 101 on the 30th of July. And on that day, they too meet with complete annihilation at the hands of Rome's greatest general. And the battle takes place outside a city called Berkele in northern Italy. And it's a complete victory for Marius. So the Kimbury are broken, they retreat, they have drawn up all their wagons in their rear, as was always their practice. And that means that they can't escape. And they run into the wagons.
所以条顿人现在消失了，基本上变成了肥料。葡萄。但这仍然让辛布里人在战场上。是的。而且他们，罗马人直到第二年才会与辛布里人会面。所以是101年7月30日。在那一天，他们也遭到了罗马最伟大将军的彻底歼灭。战斗发生在意大利北部一个叫韦尔切利（Vercellae）的城市外。这对马略来说是一场彻底的胜利。所以辛布里人被击溃了，他们撤退了，他们像往常一样把所有的马车排在后方。这意味着他们无法逃脱。他们撞上了马车。
And there, according to Plutarch, they were killed by their own women who were assembled on the line of the wagons. And to quote Plutarch, clad in black, the women killed their own husbands, brothers, fathers. Then they strangled their little children with their own hands and flung them down under the wheels of the wagons. or the hooves of the animals, and finally the women cut their own throats. It's extreme reaction. Not entirely the kind of behaviour of Danish women today, I would say. Not at all. Times have changed.
在那里，根据普鲁塔克的说法，他们被聚集在马车线上的自己的妇女杀死了。引用普鲁塔克的话，“身穿黑衣的妇女杀死了自己的丈夫、兄弟、父亲。然后她们亲手勒死了自己的小孩子，把他们扔在马车轮下或动物的蹄下，最后妇女们割断了自己的喉咙。”这是极端的反应。我想，这并不完全是今天丹麦妇女的行为方式。一点也不。时代变了。
So that's the Kimbrey gone, and the Roman authors inevitably give absolutely massive casualty figures, you know, kind of 140,000 killed, 60,000 prisoners taken. I mean, we don't. Probably exaggerated, but clearly it's a massive monumental victory. And the barbarian invasion is over. Marius has saved Rome. He's saved Italy. He's the hero of the hour. And the person, Dominic, who brings the news of the victory to Rome, do you want to reveal who that is? I do. Listeners, brace yourselves. It's none other than Gaius Julius Caesar. Now, if you're thinking that's Julius Caesar, you're wrong. It's actually his father. And only a fool would think it was Julius Caesar himself. Isn't that right, Tom? That would be mad. Only a total idiot would get the father and son muddled up. And thank God we're not at home to idiots on the rest is history.
所以辛布里人消失了，罗马作者不可避免地给出了绝对巨大的伤亡数字，你知道，大约14万被杀，6万被俘。我的意思是，我们不知道。可能被夸大了，但这显然是一场巨大的纪念性胜利。野蛮人入侵结束了。马略拯救了罗马。他拯救了意大利。他是那个时刻的英雄。多米尼克，那个把胜利消息带到罗马的人，你想透露那是谁吗？我想。听众们，振作起来。他不是别人，正是盖乌斯·尤利乌斯·凯撒（Gaius Julius Caesar）。现在，如果你认为那是尤利乌斯·凯撒，你就错了。实际上是他的父亲。只有傻瓜才会认为那是尤利乌斯·凯撒本人。不是吗，汤姆？那太疯狂了。只有彻头彻尾的白痴才会把父子搞混。感谢上帝，我们在“历史的其余部分”这里不接待白痴。
No, it is on this podcast. Right. So Julius Caesar, not the Julius Caesar, but a Julius Caesar, his dad brings the news back to Rome. And, I mean, people don't understand why we're laughing, but who cares? I think they'll probably guess. And Marius is the hero of the hour. And actually there are two interesting indications of this, aren't the Tom?
不，是在这个播客上。对。所以尤利乌斯·凯撒，不是那个尤利乌斯·凯撒，而是一个尤利乌斯·凯撒，他的爸爸把消息带回了罗马。而且，我的意思是，人们不明白我们为什么在笑，但谁在乎呢？我想他们可能会猜到。马略是那个时刻的英雄，实际上有两个有趣的迹象，不是吗，汤姆？
And would you like to talk people through them? Right. So the first may seem a little bit obscure, but bear it in mind because it's going to have, it's an indicator of things that are to come. So in the wake of the battle, Maris has obviously fought it not just with Roman legions, but with armies of Italian allies, the Sochi. And at the end of the battle, Maris had very impulsively granted citizenship to two cohorts of the Sochi, of these Italian allies.
你想给人们讲讲它们吗？对。所以第一个看起来可能有点晦涩，但要记住它，因为它将有，它是未来事情的一个指标。在战斗之后，马略显然不仅用罗马军团，而且用意大利盟军（Socii）的军队进行了战斗。在战斗结束时，马略非常冲动地授予了两个大队的Socii，即这些意大利盟军，公民身份。
So about a thousand men in total. And this was completely illegal. He had no right to do this. And it was very controversial back in Rome because obviously the Romans guard their citizenship very jealously. But the Senate suck it up. They realise they can't really go against the hero of the hour. The other indication of just what a hero, Marius, is,
所以总共大约一千人。这完全是非法的。他没有权利这样做。这在罗马引起了很大争议，因为显然罗马人非常嫉妒地守护着他们的公民身份。但元老院忍气吞声了。他们意识到他们真的不能反对那个时刻的英雄。另一个关于马略是多么英雄的迹象，
he's had these five consulships, and four of these have been because he has been in charge of the war against the barbarian invaders. But now that the barbarian invaders have gone, Marius runs for the consulship again and is elected again. So this is a sixth consulship. And only one man way back in the midst of time had achieved this. So Marius is now the equal record holder. And just to emphasize, you know, it's a big enough feat for a novice homo, a man from, you know, who has no pedigree to get one consulship.
他已经有了这五次执政官任期，其中四次是因为他负责对抗野蛮人入侵者的战争。但现在野蛮人入侵者已经消失了，马略再次竞选执政官并再次当选。所以这是第六次执政官任期。只有一个人在很久以前达到了这一点。所以马略现在是并列纪录保持者。而且要强调的是，你知道，对于一个“新人”，一个来自，你知道，没有任何血统的人来说，获得一次执政官任期已经是一个足够大的壮举了。
Marius is now the joint record holder. six consulships, stupefying. But to be fair, he deserves it. Is he not the goat at this point of Roman history? He's, he, Jagirtha, stuff in Spain, seeing off the white walkers. I mean, he's got an unbelievable record of success. And if any man in Roman history deserves six consulships, surely it's Gaius Marius. Well, you might say that.
马略现在是并列纪录保持者。六次执政官任期，令人震惊。但公平地说，他应得的。他不是罗马历史上的GOAT（史上最佳）吗？他，朱古达，在西班牙的事情，送走异鬼。我的意思是，他有着令人难以置信的成功记录。如果罗马历史上有哪个人值得六次执政官任期，那肯定是盖乌斯·马略。嗯，你可能会这么说。
But obviously, in a society like Rome, which is fantastic, founded on relentless competition between alpha males. The fact that one particular alpha male has done stunningly well for himself isn't necessarily greeted with overwhelming joy and approbation by other alpha males. So the very scale of marriage success kind of stores up trouble for him. No one in Rome like someone who is too much of a winner. That's the whole ethososos. of the Republic. And there's a class element to this, isn't there? I mean, Marius, by definition, I suppose, because of his background, because of his plain style and, you know, sleeping on the ground in a military blanket or whatever, he is your classic popularist, isn't he? He's the man
但显然，在像罗马这样一个基于阿尔法男性之间无情竞争的社会里。一个特定的阿尔法男性为自己做得非常出色这一事实，并不一定受到其他阿尔法男性的压倒性喜悦和赞许。所以马略成功的规模在某种程度上为他储存了麻烦。在罗马，没有人喜欢那种太像赢家的人。这就是共和国的整个精神。而且这其中有一个阶级因素，不是吗？我的意思是，马略，根据定义，我想，因为他的背景，因为他朴素的风格，你知道，睡在军事毯子上或什么的，他是你典型的民粹主义者，不是吗？他是那个人。
who appeals to the people. He's a champion of ordinary working people. Isn't that Marius's a schick? That is very much his stick. Yeah. And by definition, therefore, that means that conservatives, the patrician types, they're going to see him as somebody who is not one of them and they're going to look for somebody, they're going to look for a champion. Maris is much too taller poppy, so they want to nurture and, you know, grow other poppies that can kind of measure up to him. And the one that they go for is a guy called Quintus Lutatius Cacculus, and he had been Maris's colleague as consul in 102 BC. So that's the year in which they had defeated the Teutans. and he is everything that Marius isn't.
他呼吁民众。他是普通劳动人民的捍卫者。那不是马略的招牌吗？那确实是他的招牌。是的。因此，根据定义，这意味着保守派，即贵族阶层，会把他视为异类，他们会寻找另一个人，寻找一位捍卫者。马略太出风头了，所以他们想要培养并扶持其他能与他抗衡的人。他们看中的人是昆图斯·卢塔蒂乌斯·卡图卢斯，他曾是马略公元前102年担任执政官时的同事。那一年他们击败了条顿人。他的一切都与马略截然不同。
So he's a very old-school aristocrat. He's enjoyed a very expensive education. He has amazing connections. He's so not Marius that to be enthusiastic for him is kind of almost pointedly to do Marius down. Now, Cautilus initially had made a bit of a hash of things. So in the campaign against the Kimbray, it was his failure to hold defensive positions along the line between Gaul and Italy that had enabled the Kimbury to break through the defences and advance into northern Italy. But he'd redeemed himself. He'd joined forces with Marius.
他是一位非常老派的贵族。他受过非常昂贵的教育。他拥有惊人的人脉。他与马略完全不同，以至于对他表现出热情，几乎就是为了故意贬低马略。现在，卡图卢斯最初把事情搞得一团糟。在对抗辛布里人的战役中，正是因为他未能守住高卢和意大利之间的防线，才使得辛布里人突破防线并推进到意大利北部。但他挽回了名声。他与马略合兵一处。
They'd won the great victory together. Cacchulus hadn't, you know, I mean, he's not a great general, but he'd fought with dogged competence. And the Romans, I guess, they love a bit of dogged competence. They don't hold, you know, they see that as a mark in Cacullus's favour. Yeah. And so Cacullus had been awarded a triumph, a long. alongside Marius. But he's an aristocrat. Marius isn't out of towner. Obviously, Cacchalus is resentful of the fact that Marius is really the one getting all the applauded, it's getting all the cheers. And so the rivalry between them over the years that follows is kind of baked in. So Marius, for instance, he builds a temple to celebrate the favour that had been shown him by the
他们共同赢得了伟大的胜利。卡图卢斯，你知道，我的意思是，他不是一位伟大的将军，但他以顽强的能力作战。我想罗马人喜欢这种顽强的能力。他们不认为这有什么，他们把这视为卡图卢斯的优点。是的。因此，卡图卢斯和马略一起被授予了凯旋式。但他是一位贵族。马略是个外乡人。显然，卡图卢斯对马略实际上获得了所有的掌声和欢呼感到不满。因此，他们多年来的竞争关系就这样根深蒂固了。例如，马略建造了一座神庙来庆祝神灵对他的眷顾，
gods. And Cacchalus does exactly the same. And so it carries on. And this, no, it's nothing unusual. This is how people tend to behave in the Roman Republic. The great men do tend to dislike each other, to be rivals of one another. But Catullus isn't really a, I mean, he's not a serious threat to Marius. Is he? The way you've described his record. He's a plodder. Yeah. Right. He's a mediocrity. Yeah. I don't think Marius really feels threatened by him. There is, however, one man who I think does live a bit rent-free in his head. And this is another aristocrat. a former lieutenant of his, a soldier, a politician of formidable abilities. We've mentioned him before.
而卡图卢斯也做了同样的事情。事情就这样继续下去。这没什么不寻常的。这就是罗马共和国人们的行为方式。伟人们往往互相厌恶，成为彼此的竞争对手。但卡图卢斯并不是一个，我的意思是，他不是马略的严重威胁，对吧？按照你描述他的记录来看。他是个平庸之辈。是的。没错。他是个平庸的人。是的。我不认为马略真的感到被他威胁。然而，有一个人我认为确实让他感到如芒在背。这是另一位贵族，他曾经的副官，一位士兵，一位能力出众的政治家。我们之前提到过他。
This is Lucius Cornelius Sulla. And I think it's time now. We've mentioned him several times already in this series to have a bit of a closer look at him. The glamour boy of Roman politics, right? I mean, he really is, he has the glamour that Marius perhaps doesn't quite have. He's sophisticated. He is patrician. He is blue-blooded.
这就是卢基乌斯·科尔内利乌斯·苏拉。我想现在是时候了。我们在本系列中已经多次提到他，现在要更仔细地审视他。罗马政坛的魅力男孩，对吧？我的意思是，他确实拥有马略可能不太具备的魅力。他世故。他是贵族。他是名门之后。
he's cool, he's ruthless, he's cunning, all of these things. But there are similarities as well as differences, right? Yeah, they completely are. So both of them are brilliant soldiers. Both of them have a real talent for politics. Both of them are incredibly ambitious. And both of them, I think, have been very driven to escape what by the standards of senatorial politics is a degree of relative poverty.
他冷静、冷酷、狡猾，所有这些特质他都有。但他们之间既有相似之处，也有不同之处，对吧？是的，完全如此。他们都是杰出的士兵。他们都具有真正的政治天赋。他们都非常有野心。而且我认为，他们都非常渴望摆脱在元老院政治标准下那种相对贫困的状态。
So although Marius, his background is kind of the regional aristocracy, the out-of-town aristocracy, his parents are not wealthy compared to the great, you know, sanatorial figures of Rome. Yeah. And Sulla, even though he comes from an ancient patrician family, his background also has been relatively poverty-stricken. So his father had died essentially bankrupt. And so left Sulla very, very hard up. And this means that throughout his youth, Sulla had found his means humiliatingly disproportionate to his ambitions, to his expectations. Right.
所以，尽管马略的背景是某种地方贵族，外乡贵族，但与罗马伟大的元老院人物相比，他的父母并不富有。是的。而苏拉，尽管他来自古老的贵族家庭，但他的背景也相对贫困。他的父亲基本上是破产去世的。所以苏拉留下来时非常拮据。这意味着在整个青年时期，苏拉发现自己的财力与他的野心和期望相比，显得极其寒酸。没错。
You know, it's like someone, I guess, who's been given a very expensive education and then the father goes bankrupt. You have to go and get a job in Burger King or something. Is that kind of thing? Does that happen to people with expect? I mean, do they end up working Burger King? I had a friend who did experience that. Well, it's the classic thing of the person living in the kind of massive country house who can't heat it because daddy spends all the money on hookers. I think it's worse than that because if we can trust Plutarch, and that is quite a big if.
你知道，这就像一个人，我想，受过非常昂贵的教育，然后父亲破产了。你不得不去汉堡王找份工作之类的。是那种情况吗？有期望的人会落到去汉堡王工作吗？我有个朋友确实经历过。嗯，这就是那种住在巨大的乡村别墅里却因为老爸把钱都花在妓女身上而付不起暖气费的经典案例。我认为情况比那更糟，因为如果我们能相信普鲁塔克的话，那是一个很大的假设。
But he reports traditions that Sulla is hanging out in very kind of seedy lodgings in rough areas of town. He doesn't seem to have had the equivalent of a stately home. And he is hanging out with kind of the demi-monde, with bohemians. Right. And these include prostitutes, drag queens, and the very worst of the worst, stand-up comedians. Oh, no. Mym artists, people of that ilk. Prutuck is appalled by this.
但他报告的传统是，苏拉住在城里贫民区非常破旧的住所里。他似乎没有那种豪宅。他与所谓的下层社会、波希米亚人混在一起。没错。其中包括妓女、变装皇后，以及最糟糕的——脱口秀喜剧演员。哦，不。哑剧演员，这类人。普鲁塔克对此感到震惊。
One of the few things you can say is touching about Zala, that he's very loyal to them throughout his life. Loves a drag queen and a stand-up comic. He literally does. love a drag queen, as we will see. He's very keen on stand-up comics and drag queens and indeed prostitutes. God Almighty. We've said how he's a very good-looking man. He has this kind of this hair that's so golden that it's almost red, which is very striking in Rome. He has kind of blue eyes, actually, a bit like a Kimbrian. So again, very striking. And he's, again, if we can trust Plutarch, he seems to have operated as a bit of a gigolo. Both his stepmother,
关于苏拉，唯一可以说令人动容的事情之一，就是他一生对他们都非常忠诚。他喜欢变装皇后和脱口秀喜剧演员。他确实喜欢。正如我们将看到的，他真的喜欢变装皇后。他非常热衷于脱口秀喜剧演员、变装皇后，当然还有妓女。天哪。我们说过他是一个长相非常英俊的男人。他有一种金色的头发，几乎是红色的，这在罗马非常引人注目。他有蓝色的眼睛，实际上有点像辛布里人。所以同样非常引人注目。而且，如果我们能相信普鲁塔克，他似乎曾做过男妓。他的继母，
rather sinisterly, and Rome's most famous cortisans are said to have become obsessed by him. And in their wills, both these women leave most of their property to Sulla. So if we can trust these stories, Sulla has essentially been pimping himself out. He is being paid by the estates of the women who've fallen for him. And it is these estates that then, kind of in his late 20s, early 30s, enables him to embark on the political career that his contemporaries and peers would have begun in their late teens. So he's a late starter. So he's 30 and suddenly he is able to dream of big things.
相当阴险地，以及罗马最著名的交际花据说都对他着迷。在遗嘱中，这两位女性都把大部分财产留给了苏拉。所以如果我们能相信这些故事，苏拉基本上是在出卖色相。他被那些爱上他的女性的遗产所供养。正是这些遗产，在他20多岁末、30岁出头时，使他能够开始他的政治生涯，而他的同龄人和同僚们在十几岁末就已经开始了。所以他起步较晚。所以他30岁了，突然间他能够梦想成就大事。
But in a way, as much as Marius, Sala feels that he is struggling against impediments that had held him back early in his career, I think. And I think those are points of resemblance between them and maybe explains why both of them appear so driven in their respective careers. They're both in a way late developers, aren't they? I mean, Marius was, what was he, not even 40 when he really appears in the history books. And Sulla is 30 by the time he's got all this money and can launch his career. And he, I mean, he's utterly ruthless, isn't he Sulla?
但在某种程度上，和马略一样，苏拉觉得他在职业生涯早期一直在与阻碍他前进的障碍作斗争，我想。我认为这些是他们之间的相似之处，也许解释了为什么他们两人在各自的职业生涯中都显得如此有动力。他们某种程度上都是大器晚成，不是吗？我的意思是，马略在历史书中真正出现时，甚至还不到40岁。而苏拉到30岁时才有了所有这些钱，可以开启他的职业生涯。而且，我的意思是，他非常冷酷，不是吗，苏拉？
I mean, this is one of his defining characteristics. He will do absolutely whatever is necessary to get ahead. Yeah. So this is why he is very content to be Maris's lieutenant. He profits from it, first in Africa, and then he serves with. Marius against the barbarians in the north, the Teutons and the Kimbury. But he's also happy in due course when he has to to turn on Marius as Marius had turned on Mattelis, his patron.
我的意思是，这是他定义的特征之一。为了出人头地，他绝对会做任何必要的事情。是的。这就是为什么他非常乐意担任马略的副官。他从中获利，首先是在非洲，然后他与马略一起在北方对抗蛮族，即条顿人和辛布里人。但当他必须背叛马略时，他也乐于这样做，就像马略背叛了他的赞助人梅特卢斯一样。
So we mentioned this ring and how it niggles Marius. He hates this ring, kind of showing Sulla getting Gigertha. In the war against the Kimbris, Sulla begins serving with Marius, and then he switches and joins the staff of Catulus. And by doing that, he's not just broading his rinkethe. range of military experience, he's also identifying himself with the conservative interest in the Senate, because that is the kind of the alignment that Caculus represents. And that is, of course, the faction most opposed to Marius. And so I think Sulla is definitely making a statement
所以我们提到了这枚戒指，以及它是如何让马略感到烦恼的。他讨厌这枚戒指，因为它展示了苏拉抓获朱古达的情景。在对抗辛布里人的战争中，苏拉开始与马略一起服役，然后他转投了卡图卢斯的幕僚。通过这样做，他不仅拓宽了他的军事经验范围，他还将自己与元老院的保守派利益联系在一起，因为这就是卡图卢斯所代表的立场。当然，这也是最反对马略的派系。所以我认为苏拉绝对是在表明立场，
with that that he, you know, he's served his apprenticeship, and now he's moving on. He's leaving Marius behind. So in the 90s, in the wake of the defeat of the Teutons and the Kimbrey, Sala, I mean, he does well enough. He, you know, he gets a magistrate here, a magistrate there. He goes on a diplomatic mission. He's the first Roman to establish relations with the Parthians in the Far East, this kind of Iranian power. But he doesn't make a tremendous name for himself. And the consulship remains out of his reach. And the problem is that Sala lacks what Marius had enjoyed, namely the chance to do spectacularly well in a glorious war. But Sulla doesn't despair about this.
他已经完成了学徒期，现在他要继续前进了。他要把马略抛在身后。所以在90年代，在击败条顿人和辛布里人之后，苏拉，我的意思是，他做得还不错。他，你知道，他在这里当了个地方官，在那里当了个地方官。他去执行了一次外交任务。他是第一个与远东的帕提亚人（这种伊朗势力）建立关系的罗马人。但他并没有为自己赢得巨大的名声。执政官职位仍然遥不可及。问题在于苏拉缺乏马略所享有的东西，即在光荣的战争中表现出色的机会。但苏拉并没有因此绝望。
He's ambitious, but he's also very patient. And even though he's a tremendous cynic, I mean, kind of balefully so, he is simultaneously very superstitious. And Sulla absolutely believes himself to be the favourite of Venus, the goddess of love, the goddess of fortune, the goddess who grants to those who are, her particular favourites, sex appeal, which Sulla has, and good fortune, which Sulla is convinced is going to be his in due course.
他有野心，但也非常有耐心。尽管他是一个极其愤世嫉俗的人，我的意思是，相当阴郁，但他同时又非常迷信。苏拉绝对相信自己是维纳斯的宠儿，她是爱之女神，财富女神，是赋予她特别宠儿性吸引力（苏拉拥有这一点）和好运（苏拉确信这迟早会属于他）的女神。
So by 91 BC, Sulla is 47. The minimum age by convention that you can run for the consulship is 40. So he's seven years over that threshold. And I reckon by Sulla's own high standards, you know, he has to reckon that that's a bit of a failure. He should have got the consulship by this point. But he remains confident that everything's going to be fine, that he is going to get a consulship in due course, that he is going to become one of the great men of not just in contemporary Roman politics, but in the entire sweep of Roman history, and that he is indeed what the Romans called phalics, which means both fortunate and favored by Venus. And he is not wrong because in due course, he is. He is going to get his chance with absolutely seismic consequences for the Roman Republic.
所以到公元前91年，苏拉已经47岁了。按照惯例，竞选执政官的最低年龄是40岁。所以他超过那个门槛7年了。我认为按照苏拉自己的高标准，他必须认为这有点失败。他本应该在那时就获得执政官职位。但他仍然确信一切都会好起来，他迟早会获得执政官职位，他不仅会成为当代罗马政坛的伟人，而且会成为整个罗马历史长河中的伟人，而且他确实是罗马人所说的“幸运者”（felix），这意味着既幸运又受到维纳斯的眷顾。他没有错，因为迟早，他会得到机会，这对罗马共和国来说将产生绝对震撼性的后果。
And he will be getting that chance after the break. This episode is brought to you by Amazon. Tom throughout history, change has often been driven by businesses and institutions that end up having a massive impact on society as a whole. And there's probably no better example than the Ford Motor Company. Henry Ford and his managers revolutionized production through their pioneering assembly lines, and they influenced factories and working practices in countries all over the world. Another example of a business driving technological and social change is Amazon, which is increasing the number of its electric vehicles used for deliveries in Europe
休息过后，他将获得那个机会。本集由亚马逊赞助。汤姆，纵观历史，变革往往是由最终对整个社会产生巨大影响的企业和机构推动的。可能没有比福特汽车公司更好的例子了。亨利·福特和他的经理们通过开创性的装配线彻底改变了生产方式，他们影响了世界各国的工厂和工作实践。另一个推动技术和社会变革的企业例子是亚马逊，它正在增加在欧洲使用的电动送货车辆数量，
to over 10,000 by the end of this year, 2026. Now, on top of that, over 50% of Amazon deliveries now come with less packaging or sometimes no added packaging at all. It helps to avoid unnecessary waste and it makes recycling at home that much easier. Find out more at amazon.co.com.uk slash sustainability. Welcome back, everybody, to the rest is history. The year is 91 BC. and as you look out, what you can see is the Bay of Naples, the epitome of Roman, chic and wealth and luxury and pleasure.
到2026年底将超过10,000辆。此外，超过50%的亚马逊快递现在包装更少，有时甚至完全没有额外包装。这有助于避免不必要的浪费，并使家庭回收利用变得更加容易。欲了解更多信息，请访问 amazon.co.uk/sustainability。欢迎大家回到《历史的余味》。现在是公元前91年。当你向外看时，你可以看到那不勒斯湾，那是罗马时尚、财富、奢华和享乐的缩影。
Naples, of course, Tom, Neapolis, a former Greek colony. But for the Romans, it's become the great sort of tourist destination, hasn't it? It's the place where they go to get a little taste of Greece. Yeah, so you've got these kind of ancient streets basking in the sun, and you can go there and debate with philosophers and have doctors consult you. and have affairs with kind of witty, well-read courtisans and all of the things that you would get in Greece. And so unsurprisingly, throughout the 90s, as all this wealth is flooding into Rome and the aristocracy are getting richer and richer, the entire coastline of the bay has become incredibly fashionable, kind of the Santrapet or whatever, of ancient Rome. And luxury villas are starting to sprout up along its length.
那不勒斯，当然，汤姆，Neapolis，曾经是一个希腊殖民地。但对罗马人来说，它已经成为了伟大的旅游目的地，不是吗？那是他们去体验一点希腊风情的地方。是的，所以你有这些沐浴在阳光下的古老街道，你可以去那里与哲学家辩论，让医生为你咨询，与机智、博学的交际花发生风流韵事，以及你在希腊能得到的所有东西。因此不出所料，在整个90年代，随着所有这些财富涌入罗马，贵族们变得越来越富有，海湾的整个海岸线变得极其时尚，就像古代罗马的圣特罗佩一样。豪华别墅开始沿着海岸线拔地而起。
So Marius is one of the super rich who's commissioned a villa. and typically he's had it kind of structured to look like a Roman military encampment stuck out on a promontory. God, he never changes, does he? You've got spars. We love a spa on the rest of history. You've got marinas. You've got yachts.
所以马略是委托建造别墅的超级富豪之一，而且通常他把它设计得看起来像一个矗立在海角上的罗马军事营地。天哪，他永远不会改变，对吧？你有水疗中心。我们在《历史的余味》中喜欢水疗中心。你有码头。你有游艇。
You've got oyster beds. So these have been developed by a local entrepreneur called Sergis Arata. Absolutely floods the market with very high-end oysters. And then Arata goes one better and invents the heated swimming pool. So there's something of, I guess, of kind of West Hollywood. as well as Santrapay about the whole kind of the whole vibe. And it generates a massive property boom. Right.
你有牡蛎养殖场。这些是由一位名叫塞尔吉乌斯·阿拉塔的当地企业家开发的。他向市场大量供应高端牡蛎。然后阿拉塔更进一步，发明了加热游泳池。所以整个氛围既有西好莱坞的感觉，也有圣特罗佩的感觉。它引发了巨大的房地产繁荣。没错。
But it's not just villas are being developed because a few miles up the coast from Naples is a place called Puttioli. And this is a one-time Greek port that unlike Naples has been completely flattened, rebuilt and expanded, complete with these enormous concrete moles because the kind of the volcanic ash from Mount Vesuvius, which looms over the Bay of Naples, enaboard. enables the Romans to make concrete that can be used underwater. And so this enables this kind of huge port to be built. And the significance of Puteoli for the Romans is that it's a deep water port.
但不仅仅是别墅在开发，因为在那不勒斯海岸向上几英里处有一个叫普特奥利的地方。这是一个曾经的希腊港口，与那不勒斯不同，它被完全夷为平地、重建和扩建，配有巨大的混凝土防波堤，因为维苏威火山（俯瞰那不勒斯湾）的火山灰使罗马人能够制造可以在水下使用的混凝土。因此，这使得这个巨大的港口得以建成。普特奥利对罗马人的意义在于它是一个深水港。
It's basically the only deep water port they have on the Roman side of Italy that can provide the capital with all these kind of goods that are starting to flood in across the Mediterranean from all the various parts of the Mediterranean world that Rome now controls. So you've got grain, you know, Rome is a city perhaps of half a million people. They need to be fed. You've got slaves to fuel Roman enterprises, in particular, what are called the Latifundia,
它基本上是他们在意大利罗马一侧拥有的唯一深水港，可以为首都提供所有这些开始从地中海各地涌入的商品，这些地区现在都在罗马的控制之下。所以你有谷物，你知道，罗马可能是一座拥有50万人口的城市。他们需要被喂饱。你有奴隶来推动罗马的企业，特别是所谓的“大庄园”（Latifundia），
which are these kind of vast, enormous agricultural estates, which are spreading across Italy and have to be worked by slave labor. Gold and silver, of course. And the irony is that what Peru was the 16th century Spain, Spain is the first century BC, Rome. So there are all these enormous complex of mines in Spain, tens of thousands of slaves being worked to death in this kind of great landscape pocked with tunnels and quarries. I mean, just hell on earth fumes so heavy that the chemicals burn the skin and it said that birds, if they fly over the mines, just drop dead. And to this day, if you get a core of ice from the poles,
这些是遍布意大利的广阔农业庄园，必须由奴隶劳动来耕作。当然还有金银。讽刺的是，秘鲁之于16世纪的西班牙，就像西班牙之于公元前1世纪的罗马。所以西班牙有所有这些巨大的矿山群，成千上万的奴隶在这个布满隧道和采石场的巨大景观中被劳役致死。我的意思是，简直是人间地狱，烟雾如此浓重，化学物质灼伤皮肤，据说鸟儿如果飞过矿山，就会直接掉下来摔死。直到今天，如果你从极地获取冰芯，
You can see the chemical trace elements of all the smelting that was going on in this period. Right. So it's a vast kind of industrial scale. And of course, from the Eastern Mediterranean, we talked about this in the previous episode, how the Romans take over this province that they call Asia, the Western Sea board of what's now Turkey. You get these incredible luxuries, sculptures, spices, paintings, exotic plants, celebrity chefs, sex manuals, all these kind of things. They're coming to Puttioli and then being taken on to Rome. presumably as a result of all this, Naples and the surrounding areas, so Campania, and indeed
你仍然可以看到这一时期所有冶炼活动的化学痕迹。没错。所以这是一种巨大的工业规模。当然，来自东地中海，我们在上一集中谈到过这一点，罗马人如何接管了他们称之为“亚细亚”的行省，即现在土耳其的西海岸。你得到了这些令人难以置信的奢侈品、雕塑、香料、绘画、异国植物、名厨、性手册，所有这些东西。它们来到普特奥利，然后被运往罗马。大概由于所有这些，那不勒斯和周边地区，即坎帕尼亚，以及确实
cities like Pompeii, which is just along the coast, these places must be coming enormously rich. Yeah, and these at this point are not Roman. So they are absolutely benefiting as well. And I would say the whole of the Bay of Naples and Campania, which is the region that the Bay of Naples is set in, you know, it's becoming probably the richest, the single richest area in the world with the exception of Rome. You're having massive inflows of well. and goods. And if you're an Italian and you belong to the elite and you can speak Latin and you have good business contacts, then the opportunities for making yourself rich, particularly if you have businesses that reach overseas, are the same as those that any Roman
像庞贝这样就在海岸边的城市，这些地方一定变得极其富有。是的，而且在这一点上它们还不是罗马的。所以它们也绝对从中受益。我会说整个那不勒斯湾和坎帕尼亚（那不勒斯湾所在的地区），你知道，它可能正在成为世界上最富有的单一地区，除了罗马之外。你有大量的财富和商品流入。如果你是一个意大利人，你属于精英阶层，你会说拉丁语，并且有良好的商业联系，那么让自己致富的机会，特别是如果你有海外业务的话，与任何罗马
merchant has. You know, the opportunities are absolutely enormous. And there is this one particular honeypot, which is the province of Asia, what had previously been the kingdom of Pergamum, and which had been left to the Roman people by its last king in his will back in 133 BC. And it's become a province. The Romans call it Asia. And for several generations now, Roman and Italian business interests have been bleeding this province absolutely white. And the most profitable enterprise of all is to set up private companies that can then operate the taxation system and extort taxes out of the wretched locals. And the name of these cartels is publicarni.
商人所拥有的机会是一样的。你知道，机会绝对是巨大的。而且有一个特别的“蜜罐”，那就是亚细亚行省，即之前帕加马王国的地方，它在公元前133年被其最后一位国王在遗嘱中留给了罗马人民。它已经成为了一个行省。罗马人称之为亚细亚。几代人以来，罗马和意大利的商业利益一直在彻底榨干这个行省。最赚钱的企业是建立私人公司，然后运营税收系统，并从可怜的当地人那里勒索税款。这些卡特尔的名字是“包税人”（publicani）。
And it's publicarni because they are operating for the benefit of the Roman public. Right. But, you know, there is nothing public spirited about them at all. And their scam is basically not just to extort the official tribute that is owed to Rome, but also to strong arm the provincials into essentially paying for the privilege of being fleeced. They have their own private gangs of heavies. and it's absolutely terrible for the, you know, the poor provincials. And the Italian merchant class has its nose at least as much in this particular trough
之所以叫“包税人”，是因为他们是为了罗马公众的利益而运作。没错。但是，你知道，他们根本没有任何公共精神。他们的骗局基本上不仅是勒索欠罗马的官方贡品，而且还强迫行省居民支付被剥削的特权。他们有自己的私人打手团，这对可怜的行省居民来说绝对是可怕的。而意大利商人阶层在这一特定利益上的参与程度，至少和罗马商业阶层一样深，
as the Roman business class does. And so to the people of Asia who feel that they've been, you know, this is a plague. Romans and Italians, they see them all as Romanoi as Romans. They don't really distinguish between them. And so I think for Italian businessmen, if they're overseas, you know, it's great. They share all the privileges and advantages of Roman citizenship. They can get just as rich as the Romans. So what's the problem?
所以对于那些觉得被剥削的亚细亚人来说，这简直是一场瘟疫。罗马人和意大利人，他们把他们都视为“罗马人”（Romanoi）。他们并没有真正区分他们。所以我认为对于意大利商人来说，如果他们在海外，你知道，这很棒。他们分享罗马公民身份的所有特权和优势。他们可以变得和罗马人一样富有。那么问题出在哪里呢？
Well, the problem is that when they come home, they find that they are in Italy still very much second-class citizens. And so I think the more successful they are, paradoxically, riding on the Roman coat tails, the more they come to resent the Romans, the more they come to feel that the Romans are not cutting them the slack that is their due as people who properly should be Roman citizens themselves. So the discontent of these Italians who have made a lot of money in Pergamum,
嗯，问题在于当他们回到家时，他们发现自己在意大利仍然是二等公民。所以我认为他们越成功，讽刺的是，搭着罗马的顺风车，他们就越开始怨恨罗马人，越觉得罗马人没有给予他们应有的宽容，因为他们本应是合法的罗马公民。所以这些在帕加马赚了大钱的意大利人的不满，
this has been growing and growing, growing for a series of reasons, right? They have to do military service. And that falls disproportionately on them. They don't get all the benefits of Roman citizenship when they come home. So they don't get the vote. They don't get the same legal standing. They don't get all of this. The case of Marius is a really good example of the disparity of opportunities.
这种不满因为一系列原因一直在增长，对吧？他们必须服兵役。而且这不成比例地落在他们身上。当他们回到家时，他们没有获得罗马公民身份的所有好处。所以他们没有投票权。他们没有同样的法律地位。他们没有这一切。马略的案例是一个很好的机会不平等的例子。
So if you're a Roman, as Marius is, you can win six consulships if you're from Arpinum. But if you're from Pompeii, you can't win a single consulship, right? You can't win a single Roman office. Because you don't have the vote. Well, you described how Marius had enfranchised a thousand Italians after he'd beaten the white walkers. And I guess if he can do that just randomly, why can't you enfranchise all of them? I mean, that is a reasonable question that these Italians are asking. Yeah.
所以如果你是罗马人，像马略那样，如果你来自阿尔皮努姆，你可以赢得六次执政官职位。但如果你来自庞贝，你一次执政官职位也赢不了，对吧？你不能担任任何罗马公职。因为你没有投票权。嗯，你描述了马略在击败“白鬼”后如何授予了一千名意大利人公民权。我想如果他能随便这样做，为什么不能授予他们所有人呢？我的意思是，这是一个意大利人正在提出的合理问题。是的。
And obviously the Romans don't want to make this concession because to them being Roman is special. And they want to guard the exclusivity of Roman status. Some of the Romans do. So there are statesmen in Rome who think, actually, if the Italians have a point, and if we make them Roman citizens, then think how much manpower will have. they can see that it promises Rome a kind of absolute military preponderance if they do give the Italians the full Roman citizenship. And the guy who takes the lead in pushing this argument is a tribune called Marcus Livia's
显然罗马人不想做出这种让步，因为对他们来说，成为罗马人是特殊的。他们想保护罗马身份的排他性。一些罗马人确实想。所以罗马有一些政治家认为，实际上，如果意大利人有道理，如果我们让他们成为罗马公民，那么想想我们将拥有多少人力。他们可以看到，如果他们给予意大利人完全的罗马公民身份，这预示着罗马将拥有某种绝对的军事优势。而带头推动这一论点的人是一位名叫马库斯·利维乌斯·
Drusus. And fun fact, Livia, the wife of the Emperor Augustus, so when I see Nicarld is, will remember her. She is this guy's adoptive granddaughter. So there are family links everywhere in Roman history. Anyway, this guy, Drusus, in 91, he brings forward a bill to give the Italian. allies, full Roman citizenship. And to his opponents, this is an existential moment, because just as there are very good reasons for allowing the Italians to have citizenship, so also are there
德鲁苏斯的保民官。有趣的事实是，利维娅，奥古斯都皇帝的妻子，所以当尼克提到她时，大家会记得她。她是这个人的养孙女。所以罗马历史中到处都是家族联系。总之，这个家伙，德鲁苏斯，在91年，他提出了一项法案，给予意大利盟友完全的罗马公民身份。对于他的反对者来说，这是一个生死攸关的时刻，因为正如允许意大利人拥有公民身份有很好的理由一样，同样也有
very good reasons not to allow them, because the anxiety of the conservatives, the anxieties of Drus's opponents is that Rome is a city-state. It has these very ancient institutions. And the question they ask is, how are these institutions, how is the civic infrastructure of our city? going to cope with the sudden enrolment of millions of new citizens throughout the length and breadth of Italy. I mean, both sides obviously have really good arguments on their side. And so unsurprisingly, the whole city comes to be gripped by the tension of this debate, which has kind of flared up suddenly, seemingly out of nowhere.
不允许他们拥有的很好的理由，因为保守派的焦虑，德鲁苏斯的反对者的焦虑在于罗马是一个城邦。它有这些非常古老的制度。他们提出的问题是，这些制度，我们城市的公民基础设施，将如何应对突然在意大利全境登记数百万新公民的情况。我的意思是，双方显然都有非常好的论据。因此不出所料，整个城市开始被这场辩论的紧张气氛所笼罩，这场辩论似乎是突然从虚无中爆发出来的。
And as it had done back in the period of the Tribunate of the Gracie, kind of 30 years previously, so now the argument turns violent. So amid riots, amid violent demonstrations, Drusus's legislation is defeated, and then a few days later, while Drus himself is sitting in the kind of the portico of his villa, he is surprised by an assassin and murdered. Whoa. And the news of this murder is greeted across Italy with a great explosion of anger, and this anger will culminate in them turning to open warfare. And this war will be called by historians in English the social war. Worst name for a war ever. It sounds like it's been organised by the local golf club or something.
正如30年前格拉古兄弟保民官时期所发生的那样，现在争论变得暴力了。因此，在骚乱和暴力示威中，德鲁苏斯的立法被否决了，几天后，当德鲁苏斯本人坐在他别墅的门廊里时，他被一名刺客袭击并谋杀。哇。这一谋杀的消息在意大利各地引起了巨大的愤怒，这种愤怒将最终导致他们转向公开战争。这场战争将被历史学家用英语称为“同盟战争”（Social War）。这是有史以来最糟糕的战争名称。听起来像是当地高尔夫俱乐部组织的什么活动。
But this is a very, very brutal conflict. And actually for the Romans, one of the most dangerous wars that they ever fight. Because essentially, everything that the Romans have created risks being brought down by it. The Italians have been knitted into the fabric of their empire. Without the Italians, they could never have. have achieved what they've achieved. And now the Italians have turned on them. This is a massively fateful conflict for them. Right. So it's an existential threat for the Romans and it begins in the east, doesn't it? There's an uprising. The murder of Drus is a massive scandal. There's an uprising
但这确实是一场非常、非常残酷的冲突。实际上对罗马人来说，这是他们打过的最危险的战争之一。因为本质上，罗马人创造的一切都有可能因此而崩溃。意大利人已经被编织进他们帝国的结构中。没有意大利人，他们永远不可能实现他们所实现的成就。而现在意大利人背叛了他们。这对他们来说是一场极其命运攸关的冲突。没错。所以这对罗马人来说是一个生存威胁，而且它始于东方，不是吗？有一场起义。德鲁苏斯的谋杀是一个巨大的丑闻。有一场起义
in Asculum. It's in the east of Italy. All the Romans in the city are murdered, they're massacred. The wives of the Italians who don't join the rebellion are tortured and ascalped, aren't they? So this is a hideously violent occasion. I think deliberately to make a statement that the Italians are not messing around, that they seriously mean business. And also, I think, to encourage other Italians to feel, well, you know, these guys really mean business, we'd better pile in as well. So Asculum, which you mentioned, the place where the whole thing explodes. It's in a region called Pisinum on the Adriatic coast, what's now modern-day Marche in Italy. But it doesn't take long for the flames of rebellion to spread across the Apennines and reach Campania.
在阿斯库卢姆。它在意大利东部。城里所有的罗马人都被谋杀了，他们被屠杀了。那些没有加入叛乱的意大利人的妻子们被折磨并剥了头皮，不是吗？所以这是一个极其暴力的事件。我认为这是故意为了表明意大利人不是在开玩笑，他们是认真的。而且，我认为，也是为了鼓励其他意大利人觉得，好吧，你知道，这些人是认真的，我们最好也加入。所以阿斯库卢姆，你提到的那个整个事情爆发的地方。它位于亚得里亚海沿岸的一个叫皮塞努姆的地区，即现在意大利的马尔凯大区。但叛乱的火焰很快就蔓延到了亚平宁山脉并到达了坎帕尼亚。
So the Bay of Naples, this great gilded golden place. So Pompei joins the rebellion. At inland there's a city called Nola, again, like Pompeii, not Roman. This gets captured by the Italian rebels and transformed into a kind of bristling stronghold of the revolt. But actually, I mentioned the Apennines. That is the real focus of the rebellion. That's the real focus of the uprising. Because, of course, it's mountainous, and so it's much more difficult for the Romans to reach
所以那不勒斯湾，这个镀金的黄金之地。所以庞贝加入了叛乱。在内陆有一个叫诺拉的城市，和庞贝一样，不是罗马的。这被意大利叛军占领，并被改造成了一个叛乱的坚固堡垒。但实际上，我提到了亚平宁山脉。那是叛乱的真正焦点。那是起义的真正焦点。因为，当然，那里多山，所以罗马人比在平原上更难到达
than the kind of the flat-level plains. And the particular focus of the rebellion is a region called Samnium, which lies directly to the east of Campania. Very, very mountainous, very poor, trickle-down economics from Rome's empire has not reached the Samnites. And the Samnites, I mean, they're a pretty remarkable people, aren't they? The Romans regard them as backward, which I think is very cruel, cultural snobbery. So to give people a sense of the Samnites' interesting traditions,
那里。叛乱的特别焦点是一个叫萨姆尼乌姆的地区，它直接位于坎帕尼亚的东部。非常、非常多山，非常贫穷，罗马帝国的涓滴经济学并没有惠及萨姆尼特人。而萨姆尼特人，我的意思是，他们是一个相当了不起的民族，不是吗？罗马人认为他们落后，我认为这是非常残酷的文化势利。为了让人们了解萨姆尼特人有趣的传统，
they like witchcraft, they wear rings of iron around their necks, and they shave their pubic hair not just privately, but am I not right in saying they shave their pubic hair in public? And the Romans, for some unfathomal reason, find this revolting. Yeah, mad from the Romans. One thing the Romans do like about the Samnites is their armour, which is very fancy and beautiful. Okay. And in fact, in due course, Sam Knight armour will be the armour that is worn by one of the particular kinds of gladiator,
他们喜欢巫术，他们在脖子上戴铁环，而且他们不仅在私下里，我没说错吧，他们还在公共场合刮掉阴毛？而罗马人，出于某种不可思议的原因，觉得这令人作呕。是的，罗马人疯了。罗马人确实喜欢萨姆尼特人的一点是他们的盔甲，非常华丽漂亮。好的。事实上，在适当的时候，萨姆尼特盔甲将成为某种角斗士所穿的盔甲，
which I think is both a mark of respect and of contempt, because you're basically putting the Samnites to fight for you for your entertainment in an arena. But just to say, I mean, the Samnites are a very proud people. Right. A proud, rugged people. They're a proud genitally smooth people. Mountain people, yeah. Who centuries before, they had fought a great war that went on for many decades against the Romans. They'd only been defeated with great difficulty. And I think they have not forgotten their ancient glory, even though centuries have passed since that happened.
我认为这既是一种尊重，也是一种蔑视，因为你基本上是让萨姆尼特人为你而战，为了你的娱乐而在竞技场中。但只是想说，我的意思是，萨姆尼特人是一个非常自豪的民族。没错。一个自豪、坚韧的民族。他们是一个自豪的、生殖器光滑的民族。山地人，是的。几个世纪前，他们曾与罗马人进行过一场持续数十年的伟大战争。他们只是在极大的困难下才被击败。而且我认为他们并没有忘记他们古老的荣耀，尽管距离那件事发生已经过去了几个世纪。
And they, you know, they dust down their armour. They dust down their swords. They have a nice quick shave and then they're off to create havoc down in the plains. And the Romans are taken completely by surprise. And it's rather as though, I think, the sense of shock they feel, it's as though, I don't know, you're in Godalming or Tumberge Wells. And suddenly you find you're being attacked by Jacobites or something. It's just so unexpected. It's like these soldiers have risen from a pass that you thought was completely dead and buried.
他们，你知道，掸掉盔甲上的灰尘。他们掸掉剑上的灰尘。他们刮个漂亮的胡子，然后就出发去平原上制造混乱了。罗马人完全被打了个措手不及。这种震惊感，我想，就好像，我不知道，你在戈达尔明或坦布里奇韦尔斯。突然你发现你正受到詹姆斯党之类的攻击。这太出乎意料了。就好像这些士兵从你以为已经彻底死掉并埋葬的过去中复活了一样。
Yeah, that's a hell of a twist. And there is the inevitable bad start. Roman wars always seem to begin with a bad start. So there are various defeats. There is a consul is slain. But the Romans do still have immense reserves of manpower, even though they've lost all the Italians. And they do have three top generals. And one of these three top generals, of course, is Marius, who is now in his 60s.
是的，那真是一个惊人的转折。而且不可避免地有一个糟糕的开局。罗马战争似乎总是以糟糕的开局开始。所以有各种失败。有一位执政官被杀。但罗马人仍然拥有巨大的人力储备，尽管他们失去了所有的意大利人。而且他们确实有三位顶级将军。而这三位顶级将军之一，当然是马略，他现在已经60多岁了。
And by this point, he has become, I think it's fair to say, a man of size. And his critics say that this is what comes of having a luxury villa on the Bay of Naples. inevitably. However, despite his bulk, he's still, you know, he's still got it. He's still got his talent for winning battles. And actually, he had been serving as a deputy to the consul who got killed. And Marius had been downriver, and he saw corpses starting to float by him, realized what had happened.
到这个时候，他已经成为了，我认为可以公平地说，一个体型庞大的人。他的批评者说这就是在那不勒斯湾拥有豪华别墅的后果。不可避免。然而，尽管他体型臃肿，他仍然，你知道，他仍然宝刀未老。他仍然拥有赢得战斗的天赋。而且实际上，他曾担任被杀执政官的副手。马略当时在下游，他看到尸体开始漂过，意识到发生了什么。
And he went round the back of the Italians and captured their fort. And this was a kind of consolation victory that cheered everybody up. and Kep Marius' name on the lips of the Romans. But he's not the top generals. So at number two, there is the guy who's the chief landowner in Piscinum on the east flank of Italy, where the uprising had begun. And this is a guy called Nyas Pompeius Strabo. And he's widely mistrusted in Rome, partly because he has a very shady character.
他绕到意大利人的后方并占领了他们的堡垒。这是一种让每个人都感到振奋的安慰性胜利，并让马略的名字继续留在罗马人的口中。但他不是顶级将军。所以排在第二位的是皮塞努姆（起义开始的地方，位于意大利东翼）的主要地主。这是一个叫格奈乌斯·庞培·斯特拉博的人。他在罗马广受怀疑，部分原因是他性格非常阴暗。
He's always stabbing people in the back. And partly because he has a squint. Oh, no. Which in Latin is Strabo. That's what it means. and the Romans tend to view people with squints as being untrustworthy. So Strabo is seen as a person who is a dangerous character. However, he is very effective and he catches the rebels in Pisinum in a pincer attack.
他总是背后捅人刀子。部分原因是他有斜视。哦，不。在拉丁语中是“Strabo”。这就是它的意思。罗马人倾向于认为斜视的人不可信。所以斯特拉博被视为一个危险人物。然而，他非常有效率，他在皮塞努姆的钳形攻势中抓住了叛军。
And he then moves to Asculum, you know, the birthplace of this revolt, and he puts it under siege. And it looks like it's going to fall. So this is very good. So he's number two in the hip parade. But number one, the breakout Roman star in the social war. is Lucius Cornelius Sulla. And he is the guy who is operating on the western flank of Italy, just as Strabo is operating on the eastern half. And that means that Sulla has responsibility for prosecuting the war in Campania, the Bay of Naples and Samnia. He advances it across
然后他前往阿斯库卢姆，你知道，这场起义的发源地，并将其围困。看起来它要陷落了。所以这非常好。所以他在英雄榜上排名第二。但排名第一的，同盟战争中罗马的突破性明星，是卢基乌斯·科尔内利乌斯·苏拉。他是在意大利西翼作战的人，就像斯特拉博在东半部作战一样。这意味着苏拉负责在坎帕尼亚、那不勒斯湾和萨姆尼乌姆进行战争。他推进到
Campania, capturing all the rebelholds, including Pompeii. And if you go to Pompey today and you look at the walls, you can see the marks left on those walls by his artillery, by the stones fired by his catapults. Captures Pompeii. He then invades Samnium. He ambushes a Samnite army in a mountain pass, and then he storms the Samnite capital in an incredibly brutal three-hour assault. And by this point, there is only one rebel-held stronghold left in Campania, and this is the city of Nola, which we mentioned had been captured early on in the conflict and turned into the kind of the great centre of rebel resistance. And so Sulla moves up to its walls with his six legions that he's by this point got and he puts it under siege and he's looking to finish off the
坎帕尼亚，占领了所有的叛军据点，包括庞贝。如果你今天去庞贝看城墙，你可以看到他的炮兵在那些墙上留下的痕迹，由他的投石机发射的石头。占领了庞贝。然后他入侵了萨姆尼乌姆。他在山路上伏击了一支萨姆尼特军队，然后他在一场极其残酷的三个小时的突击中攻占了萨姆尼特首都。到这个时候，坎帕尼亚只剩下一个叛军据点，这就是诺拉城，我们提到过它在冲突早期被占领并变成了叛军抵抗的伟大中心。所以苏拉带着他此时拥有的六个军团推进到它的城墙下，并将其围困，他正寻求结束
revolt in Campania in his in the theatre of war for which he has responsibility. He himself, however, he doesn't stay there. He heads back to Rome. And this is It's a bit like Marius coming back from Africa to Rome because Sulla has his eye on the ultimate prize. He thinks, I've made this tremendous name for myself. I'm now Rome's top general. This is my opportunity at last to get the consulship. And so he's going back to Rome to stand in those consular elections. And does he get it? He does. He wins it very easily. And the fact that he wins the consulship is manifestation of the fact that he is the, he is the now seen by the Roman people as a person who has put all his peers, including Marius in the
坎帕尼亚的叛乱，这是他负责的战区。然而，他本人并没有留在那里。他回到了罗马。这有点像马略从非洲回到罗马，因为苏拉盯着最终的奖赏。他想，我已经为自己赢得了巨大的名声。我现在是罗马的顶级将军。这是我终于获得执政官职位的机会。所以他回到罗马参加执政官选举。他得到了吗？他得到了。他赢得非常轻松。他赢得执政官职位这一事实，表明他现在被罗马人民视为一个已经将所有同僚（包括马略）都置于
shade. He is a very, very significant player now in Roman politics. So he is celebrated as a master of tactics, of strategy, of siege warfare, of ambushes, of diplomacy. He's been given this special award by his men, which is only ever given to a general who has saved his army from a position of extreme danger. So it's evident that his men think he's Fantastic. Two. Meanwhile, Marius, the Salas delight, is being widely mocked for being fat and old. He's 68.
阴影之下的人。他现在是罗马政坛中一个非常、非常重要的人物。所以他被誉为战术、战略、围城战、伏击和外交的大师。他被他的部下授予了这种特别的奖赏，这只授予那些将军队从极端危险境地中拯救出来的将军。所以很明显，他的部下认为他非常棒。二。与此同时，马略，苏拉的快乐，因为肥胖和年老而受到广泛嘲笑。他68岁了。
So he's basically decrepit. Harsh. And he had, you know, we said that he was out in the field, but he's given up. He's fallen ill. He's gone to his villa. And he's just sitting there eating. Oh, Marius. And he seems yesterday's man.
所以他基本上已经衰老不堪了。真刻薄。而且，你知道，我们说过他当时在前线，但他已经放弃了。他病倒了。他回到了自己的别墅。他就坐在那里吃东西。哦，马略。他看起来已经是个过时的人了。
God. And so for Sulla, when he becomes consul on the 1st of January, 88 BC, it's an incredibly sweet moment. And it's made all the sweeter by the fact that his consulship promises him the opportunity to win even more victories, even greater glory and even juicier prize. And this is because while the Romans have been busy slogging it out in Italy, fighting the Sochi, fighting the Italian allies, another disastrous war has broken out this time on the east of the East of the East of the East. most flank of the Roman Empire in Asia, in that hapless province that has been bled white by Roman and Italian businessman. But of course, a really important place for the Romans, right? Because it represents wealth, East, Eastern Mediterranean, richer than the West.
天哪。所以对于苏拉来说，当他在公元前88年1月1日成为执政官时，这是一个极其美妙的时刻。而他的执政官职位承诺让他有机会赢得更多的胜利、更大的荣耀和更丰厚的奖赏，这让这一时刻变得更加美妙。这是因为，当罗马人忙于在意大利苦战，与同盟者作战，与意大利盟友作战时，另一场灾难性的战争爆发了，这次是在罗马帝国最东端的亚洲，在那个被罗马和意大利商人榨干了油水的倒霉行省。但当然，这对罗马人来说是一个非常重要的地方，对吧？因为它代表着财富，东方，东地中海，比西方更富有。
So this, I mean, it's actually been provoked by the Romans themselves, does it not? Completely, yes. So the guy responsible, he's a man called Manius Aquilius, and he's a very close associate of Marius. and this may or may not be a coincidence. He had served Marius as a legate and as his consular colleague against the Kimbray, say the year that they defeat the Kimbray. And in 90, he had been sent to Asia as part of an official commission charged by the Senate to sort out various border disputes that were kind of rumbling between rival kings
所以，我的意思是，这实际上是由罗马人自己挑起的，不是吗？完全正确。所以负责这件事的人，是一个叫马尼乌斯·阿奎利乌斯的人，他是马略非常亲密的伙伴。这可能是一个巧合，也可能不是。他曾作为副将和马略的执政官同僚对抗辛布里人，也就是他们击败辛布里人的那一年。在公元前90年，他作为元老院委派的官方委员会成员被派往亚洲，负责解决在敌对国王之间酝酿的各种边界争端。
in what is now northern Turkey. And there was one kingdom in particular that Roman businessman had been casting kind of greedy eyes on for quite a while. And this is a place called Pontus on the coast of the Black Sea. And Aquilius, with what turns out to be completely fatal complacency, had sponsored an invasion of Pontus by a kind of client Roman king. And why he had done this is a bit of a mystery, because he's doing this while the social war is right. is raging. So you think the Romans had their hands full enough. Maybe he does it because he's been bribed by the business interests. Or maybe he's trying to provoke a war that Marius can then take command of. So maybe he's doing it to serve his old boss. I mean, both or neither may be
在现在的土耳其北部。有一个王国，罗马商人已经觊觎很久了。这就是黑海沿岸一个叫本都的地方。阿奎利乌斯以一种事后看来极其致命的自满情绪，支持了一个罗马附庸国王对本都的入侵。他为什么要这样做是个谜，因为他是在社会战争正激烈进行的时候做这件事的。所以你会认为罗马人已经够忙的了。也许他这样做是因为他被商业利益集团贿赂了。或者他可能是在试图挑起一场战争，让马略可以接管指挥权。所以也许他这样做是为了服务他的老上司。我的意思是，两者皆有可能，或者两者都不是。
possible. We can't be sure. But either way, I mean, it turns out to be a really foolish thing to have done because Rome is fighting this desperate war back in Italy, and the King of Pontus turns out to be much more formidable than Aquilius had anticipated. And the King of Pontus is a guy called Mithridates, and he's very bold, very cunning, and as it turns out, incredibly vindictive. And he very easily swats aside the invasion of his kingdom. And then he takes an astonishing step, which is to invade the province of Asia. I mean, a jaw-dropping step. And it's jaw-dropping because for over a century now,
有可能。我们无法确定。但无论如何，我的意思是，事实证明这是一件非常愚蠢的事情，因为罗马正在意大利进行这场绝望的战争，而本都国王的表现比阿奎利乌斯预想的要强大得多。本都国王是一个叫米特里达梯的人，他非常大胆，非常狡猾，而且事实证明，极其记仇。他非常轻松地击退了对他王国的入侵。然后他采取了一个令人震惊的举动，那就是入侵亚洲行省。我的意思是，一个令人瞠目结舌的举动。这之所以令人瞠目结舌，是因为一个多世纪以来，
no king in the Eastern Mediterranean has dared to provoke a war with Rome. Yeah. They know what follows. They know that it's absolute curtains if you do that. But Mithridates have done it. And so people are maybe wondering, well, why has he taken this bold step? It's partly because he's been preparing for it, you know, for a very, very long time. He's massively beefed up his offensive capabilities.
东地中海没有哪个国王敢挑起与罗马的战争。是的。他们知道后果。他们知道如果你那样做，绝对是死路一条。但米特里达梯做到了。所以人们可能在想，好吧，他为什么要采取这个大胆的举动？部分原因是他已经为此准备了很长很长的时间。他极大地增强了他的进攻能力。
He has an army that is, well, actually, it's literally shiny new because, you know, his elite troops all have kind of beautiful jewelry on their armor and their swords are embossed with gold. So it creates a tremendous spectacle. But also, Mithridates, he's a very cunning man. And even while he likes flamboyant soldiers, he likes a spot of espionage himself. Yeah, he's got good intelligence. He'd personally gone undercover in Asia, and he'd talk to the Greek communities there.
他拥有一支军队，嗯，实际上，它确实是崭新的，因为，你知道，他的精锐部队的盔甲上都有漂亮的珠宝，他们的剑上刻着金饰。所以这创造了一个巨大的奇观。但同时，米特里达梯是一个非常狡猾的人。即使他喜欢华丽的士兵，他自己也喜欢搞点间谍活动。是的，他有很好的情报。他曾亲自潜入亚洲，并与那里的希腊社区交谈。
And he'd realized just how much the locals loathe the Romans, how desperate they were to see the Romans, the back of the Romans, and also how weak Rome's defenses are. And he thinks, actually, you know, maybe Rome's empire in Asia is a bit of a straw tiger. Maybe we, if I invade, maybe I can pull it off. And so he takes the plunge and he's not wrong because everything goes brilliantly for him. In a matter of weeks, Roman power in Asia completely collapses. Aquilius flees to the island of Mitalene just off the Aegean coast. And Mithridates himself arrives with his army on the shoreline of the Aegean.
他意识到当地人是多么厌恶罗马人，他们是多么渴望看到罗马人离开，以及罗马的防御是多么薄弱。他想，实际上，你知道，也许罗马在亚洲的帝国有点像纸老虎。也许我们，如果我入侵，也许我能成功。于是他孤注一掷，他并没有错，因为一切对他来说都进行得非常顺利。在几周内，罗马在亚洲的权力完全崩溃了。阿奎利乌斯逃到了爱琴海沿岸附近的米蒂利尼岛。而米特里达梯本人带着他的军队抵达了爱琴海的海岸线。
So unbelievable. Rome has lost the province of Asia. to an oriental king. Unbelievable humiliation. And yet the reaction back home is quite complicated, isn't it? So for the business class who've invested in Asia or who have dealings with Asia, this is obviously an absolute disaster
真是难以置信。罗马失去了亚洲行省，输给了一个东方国王。难以置信的羞辱。然而国内的反应相当复杂，不是吗？对于那些在亚洲投资或与亚洲有往来的商业阶层来说，这显然是一场绝对的灾难，
because a lot of them are bankrupted. And for the Italians, let's call them, so the people who are fighting against the Romans, they relied on these business links to fund their war, didn't they? So this is a massive shock. But the interesting thing, I think it's so interesting that the Romans actually think, well, this is going to be an absolute walkover. Because Easterners, Orientals, are completely, you know, given over to luxury sex manuals and celebrity chefs.
因为他们中的许多人破产了。对于意大利人，我们称他们为意大利人，也就是那些与罗马人作战的人，他们依靠这些商业联系来资助他们的战争，不是吗？所以这是一个巨大的冲击。但有趣的是，我认为非常有趣的是，罗马人实际上认为，好吧，这将是一场绝对轻松的胜利。因为东方人，完全沉迷于奢侈品、性手册和名人厨师。
They fight like women. This is because they're so rich. So basically, their wealth will cripple them and we'll be able to defeat them. And then we'll be able to take all their money. Yeah. So absolutely brilliant. It's a massive win for us. And so all the leading men in Rome, all the noblades, they want a piece of the action.
他们打起仗来像女人。这是因为他们太富有了。所以基本上，他们的财富会削弱他们，我们将能够击败他们。然后我们将能够拿走他们所有的钱。是的。所以绝对太棒了。这对我们来说是一个巨大的胜利。所以罗马所有的领袖人物，所有的贵族，都想分一杯羹。
But the man who is in pole position because his consul is Sulla. And sure enough, shortly after he's become consul, so early in 88 BC, he is officially confirmed as the man who is going to lead the expedition against Mithridates. And he couldn't be happier. And so he heads back to Nola to continue the siege there, a very, very happy man. His plan is he will capture Nola, he will serve his term as a consul, and then he will fulfill the commission by leading his men eastwards. to attack Mithridates, win tremendous glory for himself, and just as importantly, become fabulously rich.
但处于有利位置的人因为他的执政官是苏拉。果然，在他成为执政官后不久，也就是公元前88年初，他被正式确认为将领导远征米特里达梯的人。他再高兴不过了。于是他回到诺拉继续那里的围攻，一个非常非常快乐的人。他的计划是他将占领诺拉，他将完成他的执政官任期，然后他将通过带领他的部下向东进攻米特里达梯来履行使命，为自己赢得巨大的荣耀，同样重要的是，变得极其富有。
However, he has reckoned without his old commander and bitterest rival, Marius, who feels that the command in the war against Mithridates should properly be his. And remember, we floated the possibility that Aquilius had actually started this war with Mithridates with the aim of giving Marius the chance to do this. We don't know whether that's true, but it is certainly the case that in the early weeks of Sulla's consulship, Marius is absolutely on manoeuvres. So we mentioned how he has become slightly overweight. He starts to go out onto the campus marshes, the great kind of open space outside Rome where people go and do their exercises. And he starts, you know, doing, doing gym work, very public workouts, running, riding, weapon training, and crowds start turning up
然而，他没有考虑到他的老指挥官和最激烈的竞争对手马略，马略认为对米特里达梯战争的指挥权理应属于他。请记住，我们提出了阿奎利乌斯实际上发动这场对米特里达梯的战争是为了给马略提供这个机会的可能性。我们不知道这是否属实，但可以肯定的是，在苏拉执政官任期的最初几周，马略绝对是在进行政治操弄。所以我们提到了他变得有点超重。他开始去战神广场，那是罗马城外人们去锻炼的大型开放空间。他开始，你知道，做健身，非常公开的锻炼，跑步，骑马，武器训练，人群开始出现
to watch him, this great veteran working off his fat, turning it back into muscle, cheering him on. And simultaneously, Marius starts building a political alliance to try and undermine Sulla and have the command against Mithridates transferred from Sulla to himself, to Marius. and the key ally that Marius gets is a guy called Salpicious. And Salpichius is a tribune who is very committed to the idea that all the Italians should be given the citizenship. He thinks this is the best way to end the war. And by this point, actually, he has a lot of support in this opinion. Lots of Romans have come to this conclusion.
观看他，这位伟大的老兵在减掉他的脂肪，把它变回肌肉，为他加油。与此同时，马略开始建立一个政治联盟，试图削弱苏拉，并将对米特里达梯的指挥权从苏拉转移到他自己，也就是马略身上。马略得到的关键盟友是一个叫苏尔皮基乌斯的人。苏尔皮基乌斯是一位保民官，他非常致力于让所有意大利人都获得公民权的理念。他认为这是结束战争的最好方式。而且到目前为止，实际上，他在这个观点上得到了很多支持。许多罗马人都得出了这个结论。
And they're starting to give Italians who haven't rebelled or Italians who are laying down their arms the chance to become full Roman citizens. Wow. But Salpichius wants to push this very far. Sulla is, he's not tremendously enthusiastic about this. He's always dragging his heels on the question of whether the Italians should be given the full citizenship. And so too does Sulla's colleague as consul a guy called Pompeius Rufus. And so they, both of them had pledged to back Salkitius's policy. But then once they're in power, they go back on it.
他们开始给那些没有反叛的意大利人或放下武器的意大利人机会，让他们成为正式的罗马公民。哇。但苏尔皮基乌斯想把这一点推得非常远。苏拉，他对此并不十分热心。他在是否应该给予意大利人完全公民权的问题上总是拖拖拉拉。苏拉的执政官同僚，一个叫庞培·鲁弗斯的人也是如此。所以他们，他们两个都承诺支持苏尔皮基乌斯的政策。但一旦他们掌权，他们就反悔了。
And Salpichis feels that he has been portrayed and is absolutely irate about it. And so this is why Salpichius decides that he will back Marius's command, because Marius in return says, well, I will back your move to see all the Italians enfranchised. The other thing that Salpichius can give Marius is that he's incredibly popular out on the streets of Rome. He's very good at whipping up a mob. And so this is the deal. Marius and Salpius agree terms. Marius will get the command.
苏尔皮基乌斯觉得他被出卖了，对此感到非常愤怒。这就是为什么苏尔皮基乌斯决定他将支持马略的指挥权，因为马略作为回报说，好吧，我将支持你让所有意大利人获得选举权的举动。苏尔皮基乌斯能给马略的另一件事是，他在罗马街头非常受欢迎。他非常擅长煽动暴民。所以这就是交易。马略和苏尔皮基乌斯达成了协议。马略将获得指挥权。
Salpicious will get Maris's backing for the Italians all getting the vote. And so it is that a fateful political drama is set in train. So first thing that happens, Solpicius reintroduces his bill. So he reintroduces a bill at the same time his supporters take to the streets. There's rioting in the city, isn't there? It's all kicking off. Sulla is at his camp outside Nola and he gets news and he comes rushing back and he has this meeting with Pompeius Rufus, who is the consular colleague, and Sopichius,
苏尔皮基乌斯将获得马略对所有意大利人获得投票权的支持。于是，一场决定性的政治戏剧就此上演。所以发生的第一件事是，苏尔皮基乌斯重新提出了他的法案。所以他在他的支持者走上街头的同时重新提出了法案。城里发生了骚乱，不是吗？一切都乱套了。苏拉在诺拉城外的营地，他得到了消息，他匆忙赶回，并与执政官同僚庞培·鲁弗斯和苏尔皮基乌斯进行了会面，
I mean, this is an amazing thing, Sopichius, he is the news that Sulla is having this meeting in secret, and he sends a gang of thugs to break it up, and tell him what happens next? Well, in the resulting confrontation, the son of Pompeius Rufus, the consul is murdered. Rufus himself barely escapes with his life, and Sulla, I mean, this is such a humiliation, is forced to take refuge in Marius's house. So massive embarrassment, but it's not the end of Sulla's humiliations. Because before he's allowed to return to Nola, he has to acquiesce in Sarpikius's legislation, this bill that he'd previously blocked.
我的意思是，这是一件令人惊奇的事情，苏尔皮基乌斯，他得到了苏拉正在秘密会面的消息，他派了一群暴徒去破坏这次会面，告诉他接下来发生了什么？好吧，在随后的对抗中，执政官庞培·鲁弗斯的儿子被谋杀了。鲁弗斯本人勉强逃脱了性命，而苏拉，我的意思是，这真是一种羞辱，被迫在马略的家中避难。所以巨大的尴尬，但这并不是苏拉羞辱的终点。因为在他被允许回到诺拉之前，他必须默许苏尔皮基乌斯的立法，即他之前阻止的那项法案。
And he has to agree that his consular colleague, Pompey's Rufers, be stripped of his consulship. And so Sulla has to agree to all this. He has no choice. Otherwise, you know, he's going to get beaten up. And so he heads back to Nola painfully conscious of this great chasm that has been revealed between the show of his power and the reality of it. However, he does have one thing that can console him, and that is that he has this command against Mithridates.
他必须同意他的执政官同僚庞培·鲁弗斯被剥夺执政官职位。所以苏拉不得不同意这一切。他别无选择。否则，你知道，他会被打得落花流水。于是他痛苦地意识到他权力的展示与现实之间所揭示的巨大鸿沟，回到了诺拉。然而，他确实有一件事可以安慰他，那就是他拥有对米特里达梯的指挥权。
It's brilliant. And this is now, you know, the key thing that he has. It's the key to all his future prospects, because the damage that's been done to his prestige is such that only a triumphant Eastern War can possibly repair it. So everything for Sulla is dependent on his going off to beat Mithridates and winning a glorious victory. And then Dominic, he's in his camp outside Nola, and a messenger arrives from Rome. And he is one of Marius's staff officers, and he brings news of a plebiscite. And this is a bill that had been proposed by Sarpicius, that had been ratified by the people and passed into law.
这太棒了。而这现在，你知道，是他拥有的关键。这是他未来所有前景的关键，因为他的声望所受到的损害是如此之大，以至于只有一场胜利的东方战争才可能修复它。所以苏拉的一切都取决于他去击败米特里达梯并赢得一场光荣的胜利。然后多米尼克，他在诺拉城外的营地里，一个信使从罗马赶来。他是马略的参谋人员之一，他带来了公民投票的消息。这是苏尔皮基乌斯提出的一项法案，该法案已得到人民的批准并成为法律。
And by terms of this plebiscite, Sulla is demoted from his commanding. against Mithridates. He has it removed from him. And the person who gets the command in Sulla's place, inevitably, is Marius. And this staff officer has ridden into Sulla's camp, not just to give Sulla this news, but to take command of Sulla's legions, all six of them. Wow. And for Sulla, this is stunning, devastating news, because it threatens not just to deprive him. of his dreams of a great victory over Mithridates, but essentially to terminate his career in the most humiliating circumstances. And so the question that now hangs in the air, what is Sulla going to do? Well, ladies and gentlemen, there is only one way to find out. The stage is set for one of the
根据这项公民投票的条款，苏拉被降职，不再担任对米特里达梯的指挥。他被剥夺了指挥权。而取代苏拉获得指挥权的人，不可避免地是马略。这位参谋人员骑马进入苏拉的营地，不仅是为了给苏拉带来这个消息，也是为了接管苏拉的军团，全部六个军团。哇。对于苏拉来说，这是一个令人震惊、毁灭性的消息，因为它不仅威胁要剥夺他战胜米特里达梯的伟大梦想，而且基本上是在最羞辱的情况下终结了他的职业生涯。所以现在悬在空中的问题是，苏拉打算做什么？好吧，女士们先生们，只有一个办法可以找到答案。舞台已经为所有古典历史上最伟大的对抗之一搭建好了。
great confrontations in all classical history. It is the deathmatch between Mary and Sulla, and on this match, the future of Rome itself will turn. Now, if you're a member of the Restis History Club, you can find out what happens next straightaway by listening to the next episode. If you're not a member of the Restis History Club, I urge you, I implore you to go to the Restis History.com and sign up, and you'll be able to listen to the rest of this series. You'll be able to join our own Battle Hard and Legion, and you'll be able to find out what happens next in the struggle for the destiny of Rome itself.
这是马略和苏拉之间的生死决斗，而这场决斗将决定罗马本身的未来。现在，如果您是Restis历史俱乐部的成员，您可以通过收听下一集立即了解接下来会发生什么。如果您不是Restis历史俱乐部的成员，我敦促您，我恳求您去RestisHistory.com注册，您将能够收听本系列的其余部分。您将能够加入我们自己的久经沙场的军团，您将能够了解在争夺罗马命运的斗争中接下来会发生什么。
So go to the restishistory.com and your life will be absolutely improved in every conceivable way. So on that, Bombshell, Tom, thank you very much. This is thrilling stuff. We will see you next time. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Do you wish you could just hit skip on the worst parts of your life? You know the same way you can skip an ad? I get it.
所以去restishistory.com，你的生活将在每一个可以想象的方面得到绝对的改善。所以，关于那个重磅炸弹，汤姆，非常感谢。这真是令人兴奋的事情。我们下次再见。再见。再见。你是否希望你能跳过生活中最糟糕的部分？你知道就像你可以跳过广告一样吗？我明白。
I'm Siaia and I live in Ice Cove. I've made some questionable decisions that didn't end up the way I planned. And today I'm still figuring it out. Somehow things usually get worse before they get better. Apparently, that's how I roll. So bundle up and come along for the bumpy ride. Stream a new episode of North of North Tuesdays on CBC Gem. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是Siaia，我住在冰湾。我做了一些有问题的决定，结果并没有像我计划的那样。今天我还在摸索。不知何故，事情通常在好转之前会变得更糟。显然，这就是我的生活方式。所以穿暖和点，一起来经历这段颠簸的旅程吧。每周二在CBC Gem上观看《North of North》的新剧集。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。